Hi guys, we're about to do the show. How do you feel today? Oh, right now today I feel pretty good. Great, you sound like it. Oh, welcome to Smartless. Yeah. Give us a chance to catch our breath. Lattice. Smart. Lattice. Smart. Lattice.
大家好，我们马上就要开始录节目了。你们今天感觉怎么样？哦，现在今天我觉得挺好的。太好了，听起来确实不错。哦，欢迎来到 Smartless。耶。给我们一点时间喘口气。Lattice。Smart。Lattice。Smart。Lattice。
Oh, well he's like really sensitive and kind of like, he's like delicate today, he's like very delicate. I am, you're picking up on a vibe. Yeah, you're super delicate. We know who you are. Backward tat kind of vibe, like it's great. You know, just. You're picking up on a vibe. Yeah. You're super delicate. We know who you are. Backward tat kind of vibe. Like it's great.
哦，他今天表现得真的很敏感，有点像，他今天像个瓷娃娃一样，非常娇气。我是这样，你捕捉到了一种氛围。对，你超级娇气。我们知道你是谁。这种后背文身的氛围，感觉真棒。你知道，就是。你捕捉到了一种氛围。对。你超级娇气。我们知道你是谁。后背文身的氛围。感觉真棒。
You know, just... Took it off. Hair is getting a little long. He's an artist. Little. He's an artist and he didn't get much sleep last night. It's like Crystal Gale over there. Dude.
你知道，就是……把它脱了。头发留得有点长。他是个艺术家。有点。他是个艺术家，而且昨晚没睡好。简直就像那边的克里斯塔尔·盖尔。老兄。
Right? Bennett, I don't know what you're doing, but you are dialed. You are dialed, dude. Here comes J.J.'s back. You're picking up on a fire. There you are. There he is. Bellissima.
对吧？贝内特，我不知道你在搞什么鬼，但你状态太棒了。你状态拉满，老兄。J.J.的回头秀来咯。你捕捉到了一种火热的氛围。你来了。他来了。太美妙了。
Okay. Will is sensitive today and tired today. He's a sensitive, tired little boy. It's true. Well, it's Sunday morning. Well, no, it's Sunday afternoon. It's lunchtime where you are, Willie. Yeah.
好吧。威尔今天很敏感，也很累。他是个敏感又疲惫的小男孩。确实。好吧，现在是星期天早上。好吧，不对，现在是星期天下午。威利，你那里正值午饭时间。对。
Great week, long, late nights. Shauny was there. Do some. Sean, he was there. Do some nights? Yeah, Sean, he was there. Few nights in a row. Oh yeah, Sean, you did a little work this week too, with Will? That was fun though, it was really fun,
这周过得真棒，很长，每天都很晚。肖尼也在场。做一些。肖恩，他也在场。待了几个晚上？对，肖恩，他也在场。连续好几个晚上。哦，对，肖恩，这周你跟威尔也一起做了一些工作？不过那挺有意思的，真的很有趣，
some really good laughs. It was really fun, wasn't it? Yeah. Oh my God, we had some good laughs. Oh, did you guys really work the scenes? Huh? Was it magic? I mean, yes, yes, first of all, yes.
有很多非常开心的笑声。真的很有趣，对吧？对。哦天哪，我们笑得太开心了。哦，你们真的在认真拍对手戏吗？哈？那感觉像有魔力吗？我是说，对，对，首先，是的。
It was it. It was good. It was it. And then we had a couple moments we had, we're sitting around this table that's all done up, you know, the props have put the food out and stuff and Sean picks up these noodles and goes, somebody said something goes, that's really low, man. So dumb. So dumb.
就是这样。挺不错的。就是这样。然后我们有几个时刻，我们坐在这张布置好的桌子周围，你知道，道具组把食物摆好了之类的，然后肖恩拿起这些面条说，有人说了句什么，然后他说，这真的很低级，老兄。太蠢了。太蠢了。
We were all trying to think of like Chinese food puns. And he was so dumb. Was it on camera or was it just in between setups? No, no, no. It was just in between setups. And we were just laughing because it's so dumb. Everybody's giddy because it's one in the morning or whatever. Yeah.
我们当时都在想各种关于中餐的双关语。他太蠢了。那是拍进镜头里了，还是只是在转场间隙？不，不，不。那只是在转场间隙。我们只是觉得好笑，因为太蠢了。大家都兴奋得有点头晕，因为当时已经是凌晨一点还是什么时候了。对。
And then he was... And then Sean said, oh, we got dinner. He goes, I got a meal with somebody this week tomorrow. And I go, oh, a dinner? He goes, no, lunch. I try to keep my dinners free, and I said, free of what, vegetables? I said, free of what, vegetables?
然后他……然后肖恩说，哦，我们有晚饭了。他说，我这周明天要和某人吃个饭。然后我说，哦，吃晚饭？他说，不，吃午餐。我尽量把晚饭时间空出来。我说，空出来干嘛，留给蔬菜吗？我说，空出来干嘛，留给蔬菜吗？
Did you get any of this on camera, or is it just for your own? No, but that was pretty funny. No, but that was pretty funny. That was funny. Well, you were about to say something about Pete, the great Pete Thorell. Oh yeah, Pete Thorell is an absolute all-star.
这些拍进镜头里了吗，还是只是你们自己闹着玩？没有，但那真的挺搞笑的。没有，但那真的挺搞笑的。那太搞笑了。对了，你刚才正要说关于皮特的事，伟大的皮特·索雷尔。哦对，皮特·索雷尔绝对是个全明星。
He's the best, I love that guy. Yeah, he's incredible. A total stud. So fasturrell's an absolute all-star. He's the best, I love that guy. Yeah, he's incredible. A total fad. So fast, he's the first AD. He's the, for Tracy, that's the guy basically just keeps everything on track and running and for everybody in this. This guy runs the show.
他是最棒的，我超爱那家伙。对，他太不可思议了。绝对的硬汉。太索雷尔绝对是个全明星。他是最棒的，我超爱那家伙。对，他太不可思议了。绝对的迷。太快了，他是第一副导演。他，对于特雷シー来说，这就是那种基本上能把所有事情安排得井井有条、顺利推进的家伙，对这里的每个人来说都是。这家伙掌管一切。
Yeah, and so it was like one in the morning and everybody's so tired and not in the mood for any jokes and Pete was just talking about how the scenes goes and I said, hey Pete, he goes, yeah, I go, can you keep your process inside because we can all hear it. And we have enough to think about.
对，当时大概是凌晨一点，所有人都累坏了，没心情开任何玩笑，皮特当时正在讲接下来这场戏该怎么拍，然后我说，嘿皮特，他说，什么，我说，你能把你的构思过程留在心里吗，因为我们全都能听见。我们要考虑的事情已经够多了。
Did he laugh? For a second, yeah, he laughed, but for a second on his face he was like, he thought he was serious. And I could see that Pete's like, is this guy really saying this to me? Yeah. It's so complicated what he was running.
他笑了吗？有一会儿，对，他笑了，但在他脸上有一瞬间，他好像觉得他是认真的。我能看出皮特在想，这家伙真的在对我说这种话吗？对。他负责的事情太复杂了。
And Sean just did it in front of everybody. Hey Pete, like a cross, the set. Can you just keep, you're vocalizing outside your process. Pete Thorell, one of the all-time greats. Jay, he came from you, he was a recommend from you. Yeah, that's- Because you worked with him, and he's just the greatest. Yeah, Pete and I have done a ton of stuff together.
而肖恩居然当着所有人的面就这么做了。嘿皮特，隔着整个片场。你能不能只是，你在把你的构思过程大声念出来。皮特·索雷尔，史上最伟大的人之一。杰，他是你推荐来的，是你推荐的。对，那是因为你跟他合作过，他就是最棒的。对，皮特和我一起做过大量的事情。
It's my first AD and things that I've directed. He's just like... He's so great. He's so great. So you guys have worked together a lot. We've done, we did Family Fang together. We did three or four seasons of Ozark together. We did the outsider together.
他是我执导的作品里的第一副导演。他简直是……太棒了。太棒了。所以你们经常一起合作。我们做过，我们一起做过《方家铺子》。我们一起合作过三四季节目的《黑钱胜地》。我们一起做过《局外人》。
He was the first AD every episode of Ozark, those first three, four? No, no, no, he alternated with, you rotate, there's two of them. Oh, right, there's two. But I get Pete on everything I direct, if he's available, but he's very fancy now, he's working with a bunch of directors that make me look like a little punk,
他是《黑钱胜地》前三、四季每一集的助理导演吗？不，不，不，他轮流着，你们轮换，有两个助理导演。哦，对了，有两个。但我导的每部戏只要皮特有空都会找他，但他现在可高级了，他现在跟一帮让我也显得像个小混混的导演合作，
which I am. Which is weird, he works together a lot, because he said I'm his favorite, he's ever, anyway, it doesn't matter. I literally take work just so I could work with Pete. Like I really don't care what the script is. Yeah, he's a hundred. I now get it.
而我确实是个小混混。这挺奇怪的，他合作过很多次，因为他说我是他最喜欢的，他曾经合作过的，总之，这不重要。我接工作简直就是为了能和皮特一起合作。真的，我根本不在乎剧本是什么。对，他是个百分百的好人。我现在明白了。
He's incredible. He's an incredible dude. Anyway, the great Pete Threep. So wait, so Willie, I wanted to wait to share this with you today, because I already told Jason last Sunday that this is one of the craziest things that happened to me. So, Scotty and I, we're looking at real estate in Brooklyn,
他太不可思议了。他是个不可思议的家伙。不管怎样，伟大的皮特·特里普。等等，威利，我今天本来想等着跟你分享这个的，因为我上星期天就已经告诉杰森了，这是发生在我身上最疯狂的事情之一。所以，我和斯科蒂在布鲁克林看房，
and we go see this new townhouse, not that we can afford it, we just were like, let's see what's around. And my broker was like, you should see what's around. Anyways, it's a beautiful townhouse, it was crazy, it was like five floors. And so we're walking, we're walking, we're walking all the way upstairs,
然后我们去看了一栋新的联排别墅，倒不是说我们买得起，我们当时只是想，看看周围有什么。我的经纪人就说，你们应该去看看周围。总之，那是一栋漂亮的联排别墅，太疯狂了，大概有五层楼高。于是我们走啊，走啊，一路往楼上走，
we get to the top of the stairs, totally out of breath. And I'm like, okay, great, let's just move on to things that are real. Because walking up five flights of stairs is just, it's not even in the real world. No, no, not five flights of stairs, no. So Scotty goes, let's ride the elevator down. I'm like, okay.
我们爬到了楼梯顶，累得直喘粗气。然后我说，好了，太好了，咱们还是聊点现实的事情吧。因为爬五层楼梯这种事，根本就不属于现实世界。不，不，不是五层楼梯，没有。所以斯科蒂说，我们坐电梯下去吧。我说，好吧。
So we got him, me and Scotty get on the elevator with one of our realtors and Linda is her name, she's great. And so it's like shoulder to shoulder, this like, postage-sized size. Hey Linda, if you Linda is her name, she's great. And so it's like shoulder to shoulder, this like postage size. Hey Linda, if you're out there, apparently you're great. Sorry, good for you Linda. You're part of the team. One of our Reel Itters.
于是我们上了，我和斯科蒂跟我们的其中一位房产经纪人一起进了电梯，她叫琳达，人非常好。里面挤得肩膀挨着肩膀，这像是一个邮票大小的空间。嘿琳达，如果你琳达的名字，她人很好。所以就像肩膀挨着肩膀，这邮票大小的空间。嘿琳达，如果你在听的话，显然你人很好。抱歉，祝你好运，琳达。你是团队的一员。我们的一位房产经纪人。
Go ahead, so you're in the fucking elevator in a townhouse. This is a hashtag relatable, keep going. But wait, so Willie, the doors close, the gates close, I press the button, doesn't move. Open the door, won't open. Press the button again, we're shoulder to shoulder. And now even in 10 seconds in, I'm like, this isn't,
说吧，所以你们在联排别墅里他妈的电梯里。这是一个超级有共鸣的话题，继续说。但是等等，威利，门关上了，栅栏关上了，我按了按钮，电梯没动。开门，门打不开。再按一次按钮，我们肩膀挨着肩膀。现在，仅仅过了10秒钟，我就在想，这不对劲，
I was freaking out. And 30 seconds, one minute, five minutes, she's calling the realtor, Scotty's blood sugar's dropping like crazy that they're double arrows. I was like, okay, so he's going to die in here. I'm going to, like, it was crazy. And so I yelled through the door, I'm like, call 911.
我当时快吓疯了。30秒，一分钟，五分钟，她在给房产经纪人打电话，斯科蒂的血糖狂降，双箭头指标都出来了。我当时想，好吧，那他要在里面死了。我要，总之，太疯狂了。于是我隔着门大喊，我说，快打911。
So they call 911. They call 911. The fire. So the firefighters come and just, now we're like, 30 seconds is a long time to be stuck in something with that small space. So now you got a boner. Right.
于是他们打了911。他们打了911。消防员。所以消防队员来了，现在我们觉得，在这么小的空间里被困30秒都是很长的时间。所以现在你起生理反应了。对。
Makes it even worse. That would have fixed it. So you think 30 seconds is long, So you'd think 30 seconds is long or a minute. We were in there for like 10, 15 minutes. It was great. I had to squat down and like breathe. I was going crazy. So, of course, hey Will, is the gum good?
这让情况更糟糕了。那倒能解决问题。所以你觉得30秒很长，所以你觉得30秒或者一分钟很长。我们在里面呆了大约10、15分钟。太棒了。我不得不蹲下来大口呼吸。我快疯了。所以，当然了，嘿，威利，那口香糖好吃吗？
Does it taste good? Because it sounds awesome. It's not me. It's just a podcast, you know? Unreal. Sorry, keep going, Sean. This is awesome. I'm at the end of the story.
味道好吗？因为听起来棒极了。不是我。这只是个播客，你知道的？太离谱了。抱歉，继续说，肖恩。这太棒了。我故事快讲完了。
So as the firefighters pull up, there is a latch in the door. I pushed it, the door opened. I got out. That's it. And you're out. And you... And Scotty made it okay?
就在消防队员赶到的时候，门上有一个插销。我推了一下，门就开了。我出来了。就是这样。然后你出来了。然后你……斯科蒂也没事吧？
We're not too sure. He's still in the box. I love that. Jason feigned interest. Is Scotty okay? Is Scotty good? Okay, let's get to the game. How's Linda's data plan? I'm dead. And so you passed on this one. Back in the SUV. Did you ask if you could put it in an escalator? Oh God, is that funny?
我们不太确定。他还在盒子里呢。我太喜欢这个了。杰森假装很感兴趣。斯科蒂没事吧？斯科蒂好吗？好吧，我们来玩游戏吧。琳达的流量套餐还剩多少？我笑死了。然后你把这个房源pass掉了。回到SUV里。你问过能不能把它装成自动扶梯吗？哦天哪，这好笑吗？
All right, let's get to our guest. Jesus Christ. You guys, we're all big, big fans of this guy. He's amazing. I'm not, I'm not, I'm not. I'm not. I'm not. I'm not.
好了，让我们来介绍我们的嘉宾。天呐。伙计们，我们都是这家伙的超级大粉丝。他太棒了。我不是，我不是，我不是。我不是。我不是。我不是。
I'm not. I'm not. I'm not. I'm not. I'm not. That's funny. All right, let's get to our guest. Jesus Christ. You guys, we're all big, big fans of this guy. He's amazing. I'm not committing to that yet. I promise you are. I don't know who it is. And it was such an honor when he was a guest of ours in Will and Grace.
我不是。我不是。我不是。我不是。我不是。太搞笑了。好了，让我们来介绍我们的嘉宾。天呐。伙计们，我们都是这家伙的超级大粉丝。他太棒了。我还没完全承诺呢。我向你保证，你会是的。我不知道他是谁。当他作为嘉宾出演我们的《威尔和格蕾丝》时，那真是莫大的荣幸。
Before becoming the beloved Hollywood treasure that we know today, he used to write affirmations in the shower asking God to let him be an actor. Spoiler alert, God delivered. But before that, he was peddling office supplies to correction facilities in between auditions. Today, when he's not recording amazing jazz albums,
在成为我们今天所熟知的备受喜爱的好莱坞国宝之前，他曾在淋浴间里写下自我肯定的话，祈求上帝让他成为一名演员。剧透警告，上帝兑现了诺言。但在那之前，他在试镜的间隙向惩教机构兜售办公用品。如今，当他不录制精彩的爵士乐专辑时，
you can see him being wizardly in one of the hottest blockbusters this year is the incredibly talented and utterly delightful Jeff Goldblum. Oh yes, I am a fan of Jeff Goldblum. Yes, I am a fan as well. Helloum. Yes, I am a fan as well. Yes. Baba.
你可以看到他在今年最热门的大片中展现巫师般的风采，他就是才华横溢、极其可爱的杰夫·高布伦。哦是的，我是杰夫·高布伦的粉丝。是的，我也是他的粉丝。你好姆。是的，我也是他的粉丝。耶。巴巴。
The best, the best. Hi, I'm literally crying. Jeff. Sean, I'm so happy to be here. I'm so happy to be here. I love you all so. By the way, where are you? You know where I am?
最棒的，最棒的。嗨，我简直要哭了。杰夫。肖恩，我太高兴能来到这里了。我太高兴能来到这里了。我太爱你们了。顺便问一下，你们在哪？你知道我在哪吗？
In our apartment in Florence, Italy. Wow. So, another hashtag relatable. Jeffrey's doing very well. You don't have an elevator in there, do you? Oh my God. Yes. You do? Yes, we do.
在我们在意大利佛罗伦萨的公寓里。哇。所以，又是一个超级有共鸣的话题。杰夫过得非常不错。你们那里没有电梯吧？哦天哪。有的。有吗？是的，我们有。
It's a couple of floors. It's very, very nice. But I want to be relatable. No, we've been living here for the last couple of years. A few years, our two kids, seven and nine, two boys are going to school here. Lise Frances, my wife is from Toronto, she speaks French to them.
有几层楼高。非常非常漂亮。但我想表现得接地气一点。不，我们在这里住了过去几年。几年了，我们的两个孩子，七岁和九岁，两个男孩在这里上学。丽丝·弗朗西斯，我妻子来自多伦多，她对他们说法语。
They speak now three languages, because they speak Italian. Will is from Toronto. I know he is, I have much to ask. I'm so interested in you guys, I adore you, I adore this show. And just your little tet-a-tet-a-tet before I came on. My coffee chat.
他们现在说三种语言，因为他们说意大利语。威尔来自多伦多。我知道他来自多伦多，我有好多话想问。我对你们非常感兴趣，我崇拜你们，我崇拜这个节目。还有我上台前你们俩那小小的闲聊。我的咖啡聊天。
Yeah, your coffee chat. I love so much and I love this show. But you know what I love, it reminded me, is people making each other laugh. I, if I have my druthers, I oftentimes, if I really need a lift, I'll go on YouTube and see the blooper reels for, I oftentimes, if I really need a lift, I'll go on YouTube and see the blooper reels for, I have my favorites, Julie Louis Dreyfus on Seinfeld.
对，你们的咖啡聊天。我太喜欢了，我也爱这个节目。但你知道我最喜欢的是什么，它让我想起了人们互相逗笑。我，如果由我做主的话，我通常，如果我真的需要振作一下，我会去YouTube上看搞笑花絮，如果我真的需要振作一下，我会去YouTube上看搞笑花絮，我有我最喜欢的，朱莉·路易斯-德赖弗斯在《宋飞传》里的表现。
I love the way she laughs, Larry David. I love the way he laughs, Ricky Gervais, all these people have been on your show, of course. When Larry David laughs, his jaw becomes unhinged. And he's, yeah, yeah. Yes, yeah. That's so great, I love it. It is true, the bloopers from things,
我喜欢她笑的样子，拉里·戴维。我喜欢他笑的样子，瑞奇·热维斯，当然，所有这些人都在你们节目上待过。当拉里·戴维大笑时，他的下巴都会脱臼。而且他，是的，是的。是的，是的。太棒了，我太喜欢了。确实如此，各种节目的花絮，
it is really fun to watch, because you know it's coming, and so you watch the people as it surprises them, it sneaks up on them, and then they try to hold it together, and then it's full release. It's always funny. Better phrase than that.
看这个真的很有趣，因为你知道接下来会发生什么，所以你会看着当事人被突如其来的状况惊到，然后他们试图强忍住笑，最后彻底破功。总是那么好笑。比这更好的说法。
I love it, hey, how about, and then I sometimes, because my algorithm and then it's full release. It's always funny. Better phrase than that. Hey, how about, and then I sometimes, because my algorithm knows I like it, I guess, I see bloopers from 1930s. And so you see, you know, Barbara Stanwyck and Humphrey Bogart, you know, forgetting, Betty Davis forgetting their lines. I've seen that.
我喜欢，嘿，怎么样，然后我有时，因为我的算法然后彻底破功。总是那么好笑。比这更好的说法。嘿，怎么样，然后我有时，因为我的算法知道我喜欢这个，我想，我会看到30年代的花絮。所以你会看到，你知道，芭芭拉·斯坦威克和亨弗雷·鲍嘉，你知道，忘词，贝蒂·戴维斯忘词。我见过那个。
And swearing, isn't that interesting? Doesn't that make them? I don't think I've ever seen anybody curse in black and white. No, me neither, I've never seen that, no. Yeah, it's kind of interesting. I mean, I love behind the scenes of all kinds. One of my little obsessions is to go on now, the device,
还有说脏话，这不是很搞笑吗？难道这不会让他们？我想我从来没在黑白片里见过任何人说脏话。不，我也是，我从来没见过，没有。对，这挺有意思的。我是说，我喜欢各种各样的幕后花絮。我现在的其中一个爱好就是用这个设备，
and you can see interviews with everybody about the craft and directors and actors, and these podcasts, we have to talk about that. If we were really at dinner, and we could talk for a few hours, I feel like I have so much to talk to you guys about that we need to be pithy on all these issues. But I would like to talk about the history of talk shows
你可以看到关于电影技艺、导演和演员的各种采访，还有这些播客，我们得聊聊这个。如果我们真的在吃晚饭，能够聊上几个小时，我觉得我有太多话想跟你们聊，以至于我们在所有这些问题上都得简明扼要。但我很想聊聊脱口秀的历史，
and the new podcast phenomenon of which you guys are now the kings of the hill and the forum which allows us to know you and to know all your guests. So thank you for that, because I know there are people I like particularly on your show that I now know better than ever. I just saw a play, we just came back,
以及现在你们稳坐钓鱼台的播客现象，这个平台让我们能够了解你们以及你们的所有嘉宾。所以为此谢谢你们，因为我知道我特别喜欢的你们节目的某些嘉宾，现在比以往任何时候都更了解他们了。我刚刚看了一部戏剧，我们刚回来，
sorry if I'm too self-starting and chatty, but I'm excited. We just came back from a little weekend trip, leaving the kids here with their helper, with good people, and we saw two plays, and we went to a gallery in London, and saw Goya and the... Wait, with their helper, a couple of good people. Go ahead.
抱歉如果我显得太急切和话痨了，但我太兴奋了。我们刚从一个周末小旅行回来，把孩子们留在这里和他们的帮手在一起，和好心人在一起，我们看了两场戏，还去了伦敦的一个画廊，看了戈雅的……等等，跟他们的帮手，几个好心人一起。继续。
Helpers, yeah, I know. Yeah. They're good people. No, they're good, and they did a very good job. And, but my point is that Kate Blanchett, we saw in The Seagull. Oh, how is that? I'm doing The Barbican right after her.
帮手，对，我懂。对。他们是好人。不，他们很好，而且他们干得非常出色。但是我的重点是凯特·布兰切特，我们在那看《海鸥》。哦，怎么样？我紧随她之后要在巴比肯艺术中心演出。
Oh, I wanna hear all about that and I wanna talk about theater, I wanna talk about Oscar Levin. But The Barbican, I'd never heard of, I'd never been in. It's a very beautiful theater. Yeah. And it was one of the, I mean, The Seagull,
哦，我想听听关于那个的一切，我想谈谈戏剧，我想谈谈奥斯卡·列文。但巴比肯，我以前没听说过，我从没去过。那是一个非常漂亮的剧院。对。那是其中一个，我是说，《海鸥》，
I'd seen my parents who liked that. Well, my parents who took us to see art films in the, when I was a teenager, in the mid-60s, et cetera, I then, only this last weekend, remembered that I saw a movie made by Sidney Lomet of the Seagull with Vanessa Redgrave and et cetera, and you know, a lot of people people that I want to go and revisit. Anyway, we saw this play.
我以前看过，我的父母挺喜欢那个的。好吧，我父母在十几岁的时候带我们去看艺术电影，在60年代中期等等，然后，直到这个周末，我才想起我看过悉尼·吕美特执导的电影版《海鸥》，由瓦妮莎·雷德格雷夫等人主演，你知道，有很多人我都想再去重温一下。总之，我们看了这出戏。
Take me with you. Oh my gosh, Emma Corrin was Nina in it. She was the mother, if you know the play. And at the end, we went back to see the actors, all of them, it's a lovely cast, and it's one of my favorite things about a theater experience, going back, even though I love this three hour show.
带我一起去吧。哦天哪，艾玛·科林在里面演妮娜。如果你看过这出戏的话，她演的是母亲。最后，我们去后台见演员们，所有的演员，这是一个可爱的演员阵容，这是我最喜欢的戏剧体验之一，去后台，尽管我非常喜欢这三个小时的演出。
But I went back, everybody was lovely. I met Emma Corrin, da da da da. And then Kate herself allowed us to come back. She couldn't have been lovelier. I've crossed paths with her. We've been in a couple of movies, never had scenes together. But I saw her in another play anyway.
但我去了后台，每个人都很可爱。我遇到了艾玛·科林，哒哒哒哒。然后凯特本人允许我们去后台。她简直不能再可爱了。我和她有过交集。我们拍过几部电影，但从没有过对手戏。不过我在另一场戏里看过她演出，总之。
For the second time, I went back, the first time was after she did Blanche Dubois in Streetcar Named Desire, which I saw it, bam. But I went back this time and I just burst, I blubbered, I burst into the deepest tears. I do that too when I see something great, I really get moved, yeah. Or some Lo Mein.
第二次，我去了后台，第一次是她演完《欲望号街车》里的布兰琪·迪布瓦之后，我看了，砰。但我这次去后台，我直接情绪崩溃了，我放声大哭，流下了最深沉的眼泪。我看到精彩的东西时也会这样，我真的会被触动，对。或者来点炒面。
Or some Lo Mein. Yes. That was really Lo Mein. Well, I want to talk about you guys, I really get moved, yeah. Or some Lo Mein. Or some Lo Mein. Yes. That was really Lo Mein. Well, I want to talk about you guys, about food to you guys too. I love Lo Mein, I love all manner of food. We have to talk about that. But, and then my other,
或者来点炒面。是的。那真的是炒面。好吧，我想跟你们聊聊，我真的被触动了，对。或者来点炒面。或者来点炒面。是的。那真的是炒面。好吧，我想跟你们聊聊，我也想跟你们聊聊食物。我喜欢炒面，我喜欢各种各样的食物。我们得聊聊这个。但是，然后我的另一个，
the point that I was really getting at is that we tuned into your show, because I'm doing all my research. I heard about your show, but it's mostly since I've had this assignment in the last couple of weeks that I've been immersed in it. I've heard many, many things, I've, hours and hours and hours, including her thing.
我真正想说的是，我们收听了你们的节目，因为我在做所有的研究。我听说过你们的节目，但主要还是在过去几周我接到这个任务之后，我才完全沉浸其中。我听了很多很多内容，我听了，几个小时又几个小时，包括她的那一期。
And so the point is, I learned more about her, and I felt like it was the best interview, and the way you guys do it, it allows us not only to know you, but your guests in a very beautiful way. We can't wait to get to know you today, Jeff Goldblum. Here comes Sean's podcast character. Every time I hear like the seagull,
所以重点是，我对她有了更多了解，我觉得这是最棒的采访，你们这种采访的方式，不仅让我们了解你们，也以一种非常美好的方式了解你们的嘉宾。我们迫不及待地想在今天了解你，杰夫·高布伦。肖恩的播客角色来咯。每次我听到像《海鸥》这样的话，
I'm reminded of that line from Whithnell and I, and he says, I loathe those Russian plays. They're always filled with women staring out of windows, whining about ducks going to Moscow. Anyway. Is that true? That's funny. It's a brilliant line, isnining about ducks going to Moscow. Anyway. Is that true? That's funny. It's a brilliant line, isn't it?
我就想起《我与长指甲》里的那句台词，他说，我讨厌那些俄罗斯戏剧。它们总是充满女人盯着窗外，抱怨着鸭子要去莫斯科。总之。那是真的吗？太搞笑了。这是一句绝妙的台词，抱怨着鸭子要去莫斯科。总之。那是真的吗？太搞笑了。这是一句绝妙的台词，对吧？
It's brilliant. How do you know that verbatim? Bruce Robinson, I've seen that film thousands of times with Nell and I think it's the most perfect film of all time. Do you know, for years I have heard about that film and I saw the first 15 minutes, it wasn't because of the movie, And I saw, the first 15 minutes,
太绝了。你怎么能一字不差地记住它？布鲁斯·罗宾逊，我把《我与长指甲》这部电影看过上千次了，我认为它是史上最完美的电影。你知道，多年来我一直听说过那部电影，我看了前15分钟，不是因为这部电影，我看了，前15分钟，
it wasn't because of the movie. I took an exit ramp and I haven't gone in, so I've never seen it, really. And I know people highly esteem that, like you do, I know. I went down the same ramp, I haven't been back yet. I'd like to. So you and I will do a double feature. We'll see the Lamette piece and with Nail and I.
不是因为这部电影。我走错了一个匝道，然后就没再进去过，所以我从没真正看过它。我知道人们对它评价极高，就像你一样，我知道。我也走过同样的匝道，至今还没回去重看。我很想看。所以你和我可以看个双片连映。我们去看吕美特的那部和《我与长指甲》。
When are you back in the country? Me and you? Yo, yo, yo. I'd love, love to. Boy, what a reaction. Me, what? Me and you. I thought you were talking to your confreres.
你什么时候回国？我和你？哟，哟，哟。我很乐意，非常乐意。天哪，反应好大。我，什么？我和你。我以为你在跟你的同仁们说话。
No, I'd love to go to. I know, I'm looking at my schedule now and it's really tight right through Christmas. Let's go to the movies, let's do many things. You know, you're my favorite, you're my best friends now, you know. We'll be right back. And now back to the show.
不，我很想去。我知道，我正在看我的日程表，从现在一直到圣诞节都排得满满的。我们去看电影吧，我们做很多事情。你知道的，你现在是我最喜欢的，最好的朋友了。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。
Now, Jeff, I wanna talk about this thing about, I poll anyone who will answer this thing about going backstage when you go see the play on Broadway. And apologies to the listener, this is hashtag not relatable again. Ongoing thing. So there's this thing where- Well, Sean did it the other night, Jason, by the way.
现在，杰夫，我想聊聊这件事，我向任何愿意回答的人做民意调查，关于去百老汇看戏时去后台这件事。向听众道个歉，这又是一个超级没有共鸣的话题。没完没了的事。所以有这么一件事——嗯，肖恩前几天刚做过，杰森，顺便说一句。
Sean did it the other night at- Glengarry and Russ. Yeah, well, okay, so now I didn't, okay? I went, I saw Glengarry last week as well. And now I don't know those actors except for the fact that they have been on the show. Now I don't feel like- You know Bob, you know Bob Odenkirk a little bit.
肖恩前几天在——《拜金一族》后台。对，好吧，所以现在我没，好吧？我上周也去看《拜金一族》。现在我不认识那些演员，除了他们曾上过这个节目之外。现在我觉得——你认识鲍勃，你多多少少认识鲍勃·奥登科克。
I've talked to Bob at a couple of parties, but I don't think that counts in order to, what I think, is disruptive and potentially annoying to an actor that's just finished a two hour performance. I know, you can't tell, it's a fine line. Now they have to like meet and greet and like play host to a bunch of people backstage they don't know except for the fact
我在一些派对上跟鲍勃聊过天，但我觉得这不足以让我去后台，因为我觉得这会打扰并可能惹恼一个刚演完两小时话剧的演员。我知道，你很难分辨，这是一条微妙的界限。现在他们得去跟一群在后台不认识他们的人见面打招呼、扮演东道主，除了一个事实：
that they are also famous. But are you planning on being a handful? Is that what it is? Well no, but what are you gonna come back, are you gonna hear like, oh you were so great, oh thank you so much. Right, you can't tell if it's work for them and they want that, or they don't want that and they want to go home.
这些人也很出名。但你打算去当个难缠的人吗？是这样吗？哦不，但你会去后台听到，哦你演得太棒了，哦非常感谢。对，你分不清这到底是他们的工作任务、他们希望如此，还是他们根本不想这样、只想回家。
But Sean, as you pointed out, as you pointed out, you are made, generally, you're made aware, the stage manager will come and say, so and so and so and so and so and so is in the house. And what happens is Jason, so a lot of those people, they are fans of yours and they respect you and what you've done for some reason. And then they say, he's out there tonight. And then they go, and then they're backstage
但是肖恩，正如你所指出的，正如你所指出的，通常情况下，你会收到通知，舞台经理会走过来说，某某某和某某某在观众席里。然后发生的情况是，杰森，这些人中的很多粉丝其实很崇拜你，他们出于某种原因尊重你和你的成就。然后他们会说，他今晚在外面。然后他们去了，然后他们在后台，
and they're like, because it's become de rigueur to do that, if you don't do it, also the opposite is true. They go, this guy, Big Shot Bateman as he's known, he rolls in, puts his eyeballs on us. We pour it out for hours with our snappy dialogue, mammoth dialogue, and our wonderful blocking that we're doing and everything.
他们会觉得，因为这已经成了标配，如果你不去，反过来也一样。他们会觉得，这家伙，正如人所知的“大人物贝特曼”，晃晃悠悠地走进来，看我们一眼。我们用滔滔不绝的精彩对白、海量的对白，以及我们正在进行的精彩调度，倾注了数小时的心血。
It's like this orchestra, and this guy's, he's in an Uber back to the Greenwich Hotel. Now, but now really, Jeff and Sean, and let me. I'm with you, Jay, I'm 50-50. Like when I did Oscar, I went straight home only because I couldn't do it. It was just too much and shaking hands. I didn't want to get sick, and you know what I mean?
这就像是一个交响乐队，而这家伙，他坐着优步回格林威治酒店了。不过说真的，杰夫和肖恩，还有听我说。我跟你一样，杰森，我保持五十五十的态度。就像我演奥斯卡的时候，我直接回家了，纯粹是因为我应付不来。实在是太累了，还要握手。我不想生病，你知道我的意思吗？
Oh, so you instructed the stage manager, no guests. Yeah, well guests, like if they were friends, I knew. They could come backstage, but I didn't want to go out to the crowd after. Jeff, what do you think? I'm glad we're talking about this. Because things always change. And it was an issue the other night.
哦，所以你嘱咐舞台经理，谢绝访客。对，好吧，访客如果是朋友的话，我认识的。他们可以来后台，但我不想在演出结束后去应付外面的大群人。杰夫，你怎么看？我很高兴我们在聊这个。因为情况总是在变。前几天这还是个问题。
I'm 50-50 with you. I know exactly what both of you are saying. I want to be sensitive. It's very true what you're saying, Jason, but it's also true what you're saying, Will. And I always think, oh boy, they know I'm here. You know, I should go back, da da da da da. But oftentimes I want to go back.
我和你一样是五十五十。我完全明白你们两个说的意思。我想表现得体贴。杰森，你说的非常对，但威尔，你说的也同样对。我经常想，哦天哪，他们知道我在这。你知道的，我应该去后台，哒哒哒哒哒。但很多时候我也想去后台。
But the other night, and this is a three hour version of the Seagull, and they do eight shows a week. And yes, I can well imagine they don't. And so when I, as I guess is the way to do it, contact the nearest person with a bag who looked like, an usher, da da da da, or the house manager comes up, I said, is it okay, how can we, will it be okay if, would it be, you know, I don't wanna bother anybody,
但前几天，这是一场长达三个小时的《海鸥》，他们一周要演八场。是的，我完全可以想象他们不想。所以当我和，按照常规的做法，联系最近那个拿包、看起来像领座员的人，哒哒哒哒，或者剧院经理走过来时，我说，这样行吗，我们怎么，如果，可以吗，你知道的，我不想打扰任何人，
but what if we wanna go back, et cetera, et cetera. At first, there seemed to be, in this case, and it was uncommon, I hadn't encountered it before, they said, here's what they did, they were like, hmm, already making, hmm, faces, et cetera, et cetera. So I made it clear right away, I got the picture, and I said, okay, I get it.
但如果我们想去后台会怎么样，等等等等。起码在一开始，在这种情况下——这很不寻常，我以前没遇到过——他们表现得，他们当时是这样的，嗯，已经在做，嗯，各种表情，等等等等。所以我马上表明了态度，我懂了，我说，好吧，我明白了。
Well, whatever works, if it would be nice for us to go back, we're available, but please, I don't wanna bother anybody, or if that's not cool, then I wanna help serve them, et cetera, et please, I don't wanna bother anybody, or if that's not cool, I wanna help serve them, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera. Anyway, by the end, she said yes, sent him back, and she was very nice. I was very aware of the time I went, oh my gosh,
好吧，不管怎样都行，如果我们去后台挺好的，我们有空，但请千万别，我不想打扰任何人，或者如果这样不合适，那我想要体贴他们，等等等等，等等等等。总之，到最后，她说可以，让他们去后台，她人非常好。我非常清楚我逗留的时间，哦天哪，
I was blubbering, but also excusing myself quickly. I said, here, this is Emily, my wife, and all so great, and goodbye, goodbye, go home, and da-da-da-da-da. And that was it. So it was a whole, yeah, so I'm glad we're having this conversation. Because it is a thing.
我当时在痛哭流涕，但也赶紧向他们告辞。我说，这是艾米丽，我妻子，演出太棒了，再见，再见，回家吧，哒哒哒哒哒。就是这样。所以整个过程，是的，所以我很高兴我们在聊这个。因为这确实是个事儿。
Ultimately, ultimately I think it's better to air on the side of going back because it's a nice thing to do and what actor doesn't like to get like, hey, great job. Well, what about, should I do a follow up then with, because Kieran and Bill and Bob, I guess it would be appropriate for me to potentially text them. Should I text them?
归根结底，归根结底，我觉得还是倾向于去后台比较好，因为这是一件很Nice的事，哪个演员不喜欢听到“嘿，干得漂亮”呢？好吧，那我接下来是不是应该跟进一下，因为基兰、比尔和鲍勃，我想我可能适合给他们发个短信。我应该给他们发短信吗？
That's nice. I would definitely do what you always do, which is have Amanda write something up and then you send it. Hey, hey. But Sean, how was it going back? Were they receptive? Oh my God, it was so fun and easy
这挺好的。我绝对会做你一贯的做法，就是让阿曼达写点什么，然后你发出去。嘿，嘿。但肖恩，去后台感觉怎么样？他们热情吗？哦天哪，太有趣也太轻松了，
and they loved it and they loved people to come back there and I was hanging out with Karen and Karen poured me a they love people to come back there and I was hanging out with Karen and Karen poured me a glass of whiskey to share with him and Something like so we heard Bateman was here last week. What's his problem? Your name was not brought up I good once they all love so much. Nobody wants to bring your name up Because see I like I think it's presumptuous to for me to think that they know I'm in the audience and or that they want To see you right? I know it's tricky, it's tricky. Listen, listen, listen, we're not gonna solve it today,
他们很喜欢，他们喜欢别人去后台找他们，我当时跟凯伦在一起，凯伦给我倒了一杯他们喜欢别人去后台找他们，我当时跟凯伦在一起，凯伦给我倒了一杯威士忌跟我分享，然后类似于，哦我们听说上周贝特曼在这。他有什么毛病？没人提起你的名字，我很好，他们都太爱了。没人想提起你的名字，因为我觉得，如果我认为他们知道我在观众席里，或者他们想见你，这就显得太自以为是了，对吧？我知道，这很棘手，这很棘手。听着，听着，听着，我们今天解决不了这个问题，
but what I want to get to, because we mentioned Toronto, your wife being from Toronto and French and stuff, but what I want to get to, and I've always, I've never been able to talk to you about it, we've only sort of run into each other a handful of times, we don't know each other, Jeff, I'm a massive fan of yours, like everybody else, I just think that you're just incredible.
但我真正想说的是，因为我们提到了多伦多，你妻子来自多伦多而且会说法语之类的，但我真正想说的是，我一直以来，我从来没机会跟你聊这个，我们只偶遇过好几次，我们并不熟，杰夫，我是你的超级大粉丝，就像其他人一样，我只是觉得你太不可思议了。
Great, thank you, me too, me too. You also worked with a very prominent and prolific and talented, genius Canadian director by the name of David Cronenberg when you made The Fly. Yes, sir. What a film. I love that film. Can you, now, talk a little bit about that process
太好了，谢谢，我也是，我也是。你还曾与一位非常著名、高产、才华横溢、堪称天才的加拿大导演合作过，他名叫大卫·柯南伯格，当时你拍了《变蝇人》。是的，先生。多棒的一部电影啊。我太喜欢那部电影了。你能，现在，聊聊跟大卫·柯南伯格合作的那个过程吗，如果你愿意的话。
of working with David Cronenberg, if you might. Yes, I might and I will, and here I go. I love him. Here's what happened. What happened, it was 1986-ish, I think. This script came to me. I was immediately struck by it. Did I, there wasn't a, I met him.
是的，我愿意，我也会的，我要开始讲了。我太爱他了。事情是这样的。情况是这样的，大约是在1986年左右吧。这个剧本找到了我。我当时就被它深深打动了。我有，当时没有，我见了他。
Was there a reading? I don't think so, we met and da da da da and they offered it to me. And then, yeah, and it was great. He was wonderful, he was the most proactive I'd been creatively at that point. I had, I worked on it like I always do conscientiously but I was very passionate about it. I wanted to make it, like I always do conscientiously, but I was very passionate about it.
有围读吗？我想没有，我们见了面，哒哒哒哒，然后他们就把角色交给我了。然后，是的，太棒了。他非常棒，他在创作上是我当时遇到过最积极主动的。我，我像往常一样非常认真地对待它，但我对它充满了激情。我想把它拍好，像往常一样非常认真地对待它，但我对它充满了激情。
I wanted to make it work. I had a big feeling about it. And he, as you've probably heard, even though he makes those wild movies, is a very buttoned up, kind of sweet Canadian, civil, polite, delightful, smart, intellectual artist who marches to his own drum, of course. And that movie, I'd seen all his other movies, the one prior to that was the one with Chris Walken,
我想把它做好。我对它有着强烈的直觉。而他，正如你可能听说过的，尽管他拍那些疯狂的电影，却是一个非常严谨、有点可爱、温文尔雅、彬彬有礼、令人愉快、聪明绝顶、有独立思想的艺术家，当然，他总是按自己的节奏行事。那部电影，我看过他所有的其他电影，在那之前的一部是克里斯·沃肯演的，
Dead Zone, which I liked a lot. Uh-huh, yeah, that's great. I used to always do this, Dead Zone, I wanna do a remake of Dead Zone, but when the guy, you know, he grabs the arm and he can see the future, right? He touches people and he can kind of see their future. I wanted to do a remake when he grabs people,
《死亡区域》，我非常喜欢。哦，对，那太棒了。我以前总是这样，死亡区域，我想拍一部《死亡区域》的翻拍版，当那个家伙，你知道，他抓住别人的胳膊就能看到未来，对吧？他触摸别人就能看清他们的未来。我想拍一部翻拍版，当他抓住别人时，
but all he can see is he can give you traffic updates. So he grabs you and he goes, don't take the 405. You know what I mean? You know what I mean? That's good, I'd like to say that. So it was great, so we rehearsed and then, and you know, Chris Wales, who won the Oscar for the special effects makeup, and David,
他能看到的全部就是给你提供路况播报。所以他抓住你然后说，千万别走405号公路。你知道我的意思吗？你知道我的意思吗？这挺好的，我挺想演那个的。所以这太棒了，我们进行了排练，然后，你知道的，为特效化妆赢得奥斯卡的克里斯·瓦尔斯，还有大卫，
and I got together and did these elaborate camera tests which they had designs and da da da da. And it was five hours finally in makeup. But he was great and we went from scene to scene. And actually, I had a vigorous conversation with him about the ending. There was an ending which had painted me retroactively in a kind of villainous,
我们聚在一起做了这些精心设计的摄像机测试，他们有设计方案，哒哒哒哒。最后光是上妆就要花五个小时。但他真的很棒，我们一场接一场地拍。实际上，我和他关于结局有过一次激烈的讨论。原本有一个结局，在某种程度上把我追溯性地塑造成了一个反派，
even though I tried to kill her at the end and meld all three of us. And then she goes with this guy, John Getz. She kind of gets with him finally. And by that time I had so kind of, I was such an advocate and a passionate protector of my character, I was possessive and I didn't want her to wind up with him.
尽管最后我试图杀了她，并且把我们三个人融合在一起。然后她跟这个叫约翰·盖茨的家伙在一起了。她最后基本上跟他在一起了。而到那个时候，我已经成了我角色的狂热拥护者和充满激情的保护者，我有着强烈的占有欲，我不想让她最后跟他在一起。
Wow. And I said, you know, wait a minute, wait a minute, couldn't it be that, et cetera, et cetera, I had some dumb idiot conversations, who was I to talk to him about that, but as it be that, et cetera, et cetera. I had some dumb idiot conversations, who was I to talk to him about that? But as it turns out, it kind of wound up ending kind of like that with her killing me. We don't have that aftermath where the bad guy's gone and she's now with this other guy.
哇。我说，你知道，等一下，等一下，难道不能是这样，等等等等，我说了些很蠢的蠢话，我算老几啊，居然敢跟他讨论这个，但事实证明，最后结局差不多也就是那样，她杀了我。我们没有那种坏蛋消失了、她现在跟另一个家伙在一起的后续。
So I was happy about that. But it was a very arduous, but lovely, passionate experience, et cetera, et cetera. I could tell you much about it. It's a great film. It really about it. It's a great film. It really loved it. It's a great film. Do you think that was the one that kind of really,
所以我对此挺高兴的。但那是一次非常艰辛，却又美好、充满激情的经历，等等等等。关于这个我可以跟你聊很多。这是一部伟大的电影。这真的关于这个。这是一部伟大的电影。真的太喜欢了。这是一部伟大的电影。你觉得那是真正让你，
I mean, you've done tons of work before then. Was that the movie that put you over the top or Invasion of the Body Snatchers or what was the one that kind of like was? Big Chill was before that, right? Oh, Big Chill, right, Big Chill. Yes, yes, it was stepping stone to one thing led to another and luckily, because I was, like my teacher, Sandy Meisner said, it takes 20 years
我是说，你在那之前已经拍了大量作品了。那是让你大红大紫的电影，还是《人体异形》之类的，或者是哪一部可以说是？《大寒》是在那之前吧？哦，《大寒》，对，《大寒》。是的，是的，那是一个阶梯，一环扣一环，幸运的是，因为我，就像我的老师桑迪·迈斯纳说的，要花20年
to even call yourself an actor. Now luckily I had right away, miraculously, good, some parts, but small parts that led to bigger parts and I felt like I was learning and, you know, I guess career-wise, even though that hasn't been my focus, you know, from the start, one thing did lead to another. So yeah, there was, well, I worked with Altman
才能真正称自己为演员。现在幸运的是，我一出道就奇迹般地得到了一些好角色，虽然是小角色，但它们为大角色铺平了道路，我觉得我一直在学习，你知道的，从职业角度来看，尽管这从一开始就不是我的重点，但事情确实是一环扣一环的。所以，是的，我跟奥特曼合作过，
and I did that movie Nashville, very little part. California Split, yeah. That was nice to be in, in California Split. But then Invasion of the Body, so naturally there's Philip Kaufman, fantastic. And I did a movie in 76 before that with Joan Micklin Silver that I got some attention for and that led to some other things.
我还拍了那部电影《纳什维尔》，戏份非常少。还有《加州分裂》，对。能参演《加州分裂》挺不错的。但然后是《人体异形》，自然有菲利普·考夫曼，太棒了。我在76年之前还拍过琼·米克林·西尔弗的一部电影，那部电影让我受到了一些关注，这也促成了其他一些事情。
Actually, Lawrence Kestin saw that and I think that's what led him to be attracted to putting me in the big chill, which led to, yeah, now we're up to the fly and you know, et cetera, et cetera. We're up to. But wait, so. Any truth to you doing the prequel, the maggot?
实际上，劳伦斯·卡斯丹看到了那部电影，我认为正是那部电影吸引他把我放进了《大寒》，这就引出了，是的，现在我们拍到了《变蝇人》，你知道的，等等等等。我们拍到了。但是等等。你演前传《蛆虫》有什么真实性吗？
No? Yeah. Jesus. Nice, Jason. Yeah, Jason, good for you, dude. You give me a little bit of time, I will work on some stuff, yeah. No, but you know, you have done, you have played, you have done so,
没有？对。天呐。不错，杰森。对，杰森，干得漂亮，老兄。你给我一点时间，我会去搞定一些的，对。不，但你知道的，你演过，你扮演过，你做过很多，
you've been very prolific and you've made a lot of films, and so I always want to know, we always sort of ask, what was the first thing, you talked about your parents taking you to see film when you were a teenager, which is great, so I'm sure of asked, what was the first thing, you talked about your parents taking you to see film when you were a teenager, which is great. So I'm sure that that maybe you tell us inspired you, but what was your first professional gig where you went, I'm gonna do this,
你一直非常高产，拍了大量电影，所以我总是想知道，我们总是会问，第一部作品是什么，你谈到你的父母在你十几岁时带你去看电影，这很棒，所以我确信你可能会告诉我们是什么启发了你，但你的第一份专业工作是什么，当时你觉得，我要做这个，
and then you actually went out and did it and worked and did a job? Good question. It was a wild adventure of the heart when I was 10 years old. The seed was sort of planted. I got the bug. I was in this camp, gaga gaga.
然后你真的付诸行动、去工作并完成了一份工作？好问题。那是我十岁时的一次疯狂的心灵冒险。种子就这样种下了。我入行了。我在这个营地里，嘎嘎嘎嘎。
I was a part of this drama show. And my dad had already said, if you find something you love to do, that might be a vocational lighthouse and compass. Something clicked in me after this kind of thing when I was 10. and I thought to myself and kept secret to myself, this is what I want to do. I had it then.
我曾参加过这样一个戏剧演出。我爸爸之前就说过，如果你找到了自己热爱的事物，那它可能会成为你职业生涯的灯塔与指南。大约在我10岁时，经历过这种事后，我内心有什么东西被触动了，我暗暗对自己说，这就是我想做的事。从那时起我就坚定了。
This was a theater camp? No. You know, it was a Chatham in Pittsburgh where I'm from, Music Day Camp it was called. It wasn't sleepover, it was six weeks, and they had, I loved this group of people that was different and more my family than the kids I'd gone to school with. And I seemed to excel at art and piano
这是一个戏剧夏令营吗？不是。你知道的，是在我老家匹兹堡的查塔姆，当时那叫音乐日间夏令营。不是那种寄宿的，为期六周，我很喜欢那群人，他们与我和学校里那些孩子不同，比他们更像我的家人。而且我似乎在艺术、钢琴
and badminton and softball and arts and crafts. And they had this acting little moment in the day. And at the end of the six weeks, they cast me in this Gilbert and Sullivan takeoff thing where I'd sang and I was the lead in that, and I kind of rehearsed with my mom and da da da da, and I leaped, leapt on stage, which was my first entrance, and that was it, and I got some laughs,
还有羽毛球、垒球以及工艺美术方面都很擅长。他们在每天的活动中有一个小小的表演环节。在六周结束时，他们让我参演了一部吉尔伯特和沙利文的歌剧模仿秀，我在里面唱歌，还是主角。我跟我妈排练过，啦啦啦啦，然后我蹦着跳着上了台，那是我的第一次登台，就这样，我博得了一些笑声，
and it was fun, it was exhilarating, and it was after that that they said, hey, how'd you like that? And I went, I like that, I like that. But I kept it. That drug. Did that inform high school choices and college choices, no?
那很有趣，让人振奋。就是在那个时候，他们问我，嘿，你觉得怎么样？我说，我喜欢，我喜欢这个。但我把这份感觉藏了起来。那种感觉就像毒品。这有没有影响你对高中和大学的选择，没有吗？
Well, here's what happened, briefly. The, between ninth and 10th and 10th and 11th grades in Pittsburgh, there was a six week offering at Carnegie Mellon University in art and I'd had some flair for that and then music, da da da da. And my mom was taking me through the brochure and she said, you want to go to this thing? I said, yeah.
嗯，事情是这样的，简单来说。在匹兹堡上九年级到十年级、十年级到十一年级之间，卡耐基梅隆大学有一个为期六周的艺术项目，我当时在那方面有点天赋，还有音乐，啦啦啦啦。我妈妈带着我翻看宣传册，她问，你想去参加这个吗？我说，想。
She said, well, they have this acting thing. I said, maybe, maybe the acting thing. Maybe I'll do that. Really? Yes. Well, I did that and I was by the end of that Maybe this, the acting thing, maybe I'll do that, really? Yes, well, I did that and I was, by the end of that, and I did it for two years running, I was deeply in love with that campus and acting.
她说，哦，他们有个表演项目。我说，也许吧，也许那个表演项目不错。也许我会去试试。真的吗？是的。嗯，我去了，在那结束时，也许那个表演项目不错，也许我会去试试，真的吗？是的，嗯，我去了，在那结束时——我连续两年参加了这个项目——我深深地爱上了那个校园和表演。
And that's when I started to write on the shower door every morning, please God let me be an actor. And then I tried out for that school, they turned me down. I gave a couple of bad auditions to get into the school. They turned me down. I gave a couple of bad, you know, I gave a bad audition to get into the school. It's very competitive. But one of the teachers there, Mordecai Loner, said, oh, I used to teach with Sandy Meisner.
也就是从那时起，我每天早晨都在淋浴间的玻璃门上写：上帝啊，求求让我成为一名演员吧。后来我去考那所学校，他们把我拒绝了。我为了进那所学校做了几次糟糕的试镜。他们把我拒绝了。我做了几次糟糕的——你知道的，我做了一场糟糕的试镜想进那所学校。竞争非常激烈。但那里的一位老师，莫迪凯·洛纳，说，哦，我以前跟桑迪·迈斯纳一起教过书。
I took with him, then I taught with him. You know, I'll help you on audition if you want to go to New York and audition for NYU. And then check in with Sandy Meisner. I did Sandy Meisner. I lied about my age. You weren't supposed to be 17, but I said I was a year older than I was. I got in and that's what happened.
我曾跟他学习，后来又跟他一起教学。你知道的，如果你想去纽约参加纽约大学的面试，我可以帮你的面试出谋划策。然后去找桑迪·迈斯纳报道。我上了桑迪·迈斯纳的课。我隐瞒了年龄。你本不该只有17岁，但我说我比实际年龄大一岁。我被录取了，事情就是这样。
I went to the neighborhood playhouse in 1970 when I graduated high school and at 17, just turning 18 that fall, started that course. That's cool. You always hear stories about people lying about their age to get in the Army, never to get into theater school. Yeah.
我在1970年高中毕业时去了邻里剧场，当时17岁，那年秋天刚满18岁，就开始了那门课程。太酷了。你总能听到有人为了参军而谎报年龄的故事，从没听过为了进戏剧学校而谎报年龄的。是啊。
But no college, Jeff? No college. Good for you. Being in that college for six weeks, that was it. Jason and I respect that. Yeah, well done. Well, that's good, but this was a fancy two-year program of if you really wanted to be an actor, and I think,
但你没上过大学，杰夫？没有上大学。真了不起。在那个大学待了六周，就那样了。杰森和我都对此肃然起敬。对，干得漂亮。嗯，这很好，但这其实是一个高档的两年制项目，如果你真的想成为一名演员的话，而且我认为，
and they used to, Sandy Meisner and other people that imitated him have a jaundiced eye make kind of comments about the college programs. He did at the time, going, mm, that's not where you learn to act. We from the group theater know what we're doing and they require you to be a little more cerebral and academic and this is about, this is a real studio
他们过去——桑迪·迈斯纳以及其他模仿他的人——对大学项目有一种偏见和批判的态度。他当时就是这样，觉得，嗯，那可不是你学表演的地方。我们剧团（Group Theatre）的人才知道自己在做什么，而大学要求你更偏向理性和学术，而我们这是真正的制片厂，
and I'm gonna teach you the real thing. And he was that real thing and I was imbued with that. That's so cool. Talk to me about, is this true, one of your survival jobs was to do office supplies for prisoners, like to get them office supplies? As you said. Like how in the world did that?
我要教你真正的东西。他就是那种真正的大师，而我深受其影响。太酷了。跟我讲讲，这是真的吗，你的第一份维持生计的工作是给囚犯准备办公用品，比如给他们提供办公用品？正如你所说。这到底是怎么回事？
Sharp pencils and things like that. Yeah, like how in the world did you get that job? He had to blunt them, He had to blunt them. He had to blunt them. Here's what happened. That's a nice red drink you're drinking there, Jason. Oh, thank you. It's just red wine that's spoiled.
削尖的铅笔之类的东西。对，你到底是怎么找到那份工作的？他得把它们弄钝，他得把它们弄钝。他得把它们弄钝。事情是这样的。你喝的那杯红色的饮料看起来很不错，杰森。哦，谢谢。这只是变质了的红酒。
Really? No. No, it's electrolytes. I like a nice, oh, I see it's like a Gatorade. I like a nice mocktail these days. Yeah. You know, I've enjoyed a couple of those recently. I think they're starting to get that down.
真的吗？不是。不，这是电解质饮料。我喜欢一杯不错的，哦，我看这就像佳得乐。我现在挺喜欢无酒精鸡尾酒的。是的。你知道的，我最近挺喜欢喝几杯的。我觉得他们现在开始掌握诀窍了。
All these restaurants have on the menu, you know, ooh, they're good. They're really good. But the answer to the question, oh yes, so I lucked into, like I say, a couple of jobs to Gentlemen of Verona. The first thing I did on stage at the Delacorte was a big hit, Raoul Julia was in it,
所有这些 restaurants 的菜单上都有，你知道的，噢，它们很好喝。真的很好喝。不过对于那个问题的回答，哦对，所以我很幸运地，就像我说的，得到了几份工作，比如《维罗纳的二绅士》。我在德拉科特剧院舞台上做的第一件事就是个大热门，劳尔·朱莉娅也在里面，
Galt McDermott wrote the music. I was in the chorus, I just kind of lucked into that. And then it went to Broadway. I stopped the second year with Sandy Meisner, did this year on Broadway as one of the chorus members and understudied one of the bigger parts, and then went back and finished that second year work with Bill Esper, who people may know.
高尔·麦克德莫特创作了音乐。我在合唱团里，我算是瞎猫碰死耗子撞上了。后来这部剧搬到了百老汇。我在桑迪·迈斯纳那儿上了第二年课中途停了下来，在百老汇演了一年合唱团成员，并为其中一个大角色担任候补，然后回去完成了比尔·埃斯珀（大家可能都知道他）手下的第二年学业。
So I did that and then auditioned for a play, I'll Grind It to Coca-Cola, got that, and then Altman saw me in that, and I auditioned for my first movie, which was Death Wish, and I started to work right away, in other words. And I was even supporting myself and all that, except when I came to California, and this is four years later after doing Nashville
所以我做完这些后去试镜了一部戏剧，我把它磨成可口可乐，拿到了角色，然后阿尔特曼在那个剧里看到了我，我去试镜了我的第一部电影，那就是《猛龙怪客》，然后我就立刻开始工作了，换句话说。我甚至能养活自己了，诸如此类，除了我来到加州的时候——这是演完《纳什维尔》四年后，
and a couple other things, and kind of moved out here and got an agent, Abby Greschler. There was a moment when I was paying rent and my money was getting low and I thought, geez, I looked in the trade papers and they said, hey, you an out of work actor, you wanna make a little money, come and do this thing.
和另外几部作品之后——我搬到了这里，找了一个经纪人，艾比·格雷斯勒。有一段时间我在付房租，而我的钱越来越少，我想，天哪，我看了看行业报纸，上面说，嘿，你是个失业的演员吗，你想赚点快钱吗，来做这个吧。
So I joined this boiler room operation, which I guess is illegal, at six in the morning, you go to Hollywood and you go to this place and you call correction institutions on the East Coast and you say, hi, I'm Bob, and we have a government surplus program just went bust, and we have a surplus of magic markers and pens and pencils. Can I send you, do you use the green or the red
于是我加入了一家高压推销公司（这大概是非法的），每天早上六点，你到好莱坞的一个地方，然后你给东海岸的惩教机构打电话，你说，嗨，我是鲍勃，我们有一个政府剩余物资项目刚刚破产了，我们有大量的记号笔、钢笔和铅笔。我能给你寄一些吗，你们用绿色的、红色的
or the blue? Can I send you a gross of the, you know, and you get them to commit to that is my least favorite thing. And maybe not coincidentally, after a week of that was only my straight job ever, after a week of that, I got this illness. I wound up in the hospital.
还是蓝系的？我能给你寄一罗……你知道的，你让他们答应买这个，这是我最讨厌的事。也许并非巧合，在那之后的一周——这也是我唯一的一份正经工作——在那之后的一周，我生病了。我最后进了医院。
I'm just too sensitive for that kind of regular work. And after that, I went back to supporting myself, luckily, and ever since, with acting. That's amazing. Well, Jeff, so you're saying that selling the markers wasn't a highlight of your career. Oh! Yes!
我对于那种常规工作实在太敏感了。幸运的是，在那之后，我又回到了靠表演养活自己的状态，从那以后一直如此。太棒了。好吧，杰夫，所以你的意思是，卖记号笔并不是你职业生涯的高光时刻。哦！是的！
Why not, why not, why not, why not, why not, why not, wow! I didn't get that at first. Wow, that's very good. You guys are sharp as tacks. It was a... It's a tick, it's a tick. By the way, remember Cats and Dogs? We did that movie together,
为什么不，为什么不，为什么不，为什么不，为什么不，为什么不，哇！我一开始没听出来。哇，太棒了。你们的反应真快。这是一个……这是一个梗，这是一个梗。顺便说一句，还记得《猫狗大战》吗？我们一起拍过那部电影，
although we weren't on screen together. Remember that movie? I have, look, I know, I have, these are all the things I want to talk to you about, but I wrote down several things. Notes for you, Sean. Well, several things that overlap with us, connections that we have.
尽管我们在银幕上没有对手戏。还记得那部电影吗？我有，听着，我知道，我有，这些都是我想跟你聊的事情，但我写下了好几件事。给你的笔记，肖恩。嗯，有几件跟我们有重叠的事，我们之间的联系。
And I have, not only Will and Grace, but Cats and Dogs and so, really? Okay, watch this. So here it is. I have Sean Hayes. Hey, I like that. I like just free associating anyway. Anyway, now here's our connections.
而且我不仅有《威尔和格蕾丝》，还有《猫狗大战》等等，真的吗？好吧，看着。所以就是这样。我有肖恩·海耶斯。嘿，我喜欢这样。反正我也喜欢自由联想。不管怎样，现在这是我们的联系。
Oh my God, well, Will and Grace, Cats and Dogs. Hey, well of course you portrayed Jerry Lewis and I was supposed to play his son in that last movie he did, Max Rose. Oh wow. Which Kevin Pollak finally did because I had a scheduling thing but Jerry and I hung out in order to bond
天哪，好吧，《威尔和格蕾丝》，《猫狗大战》。嘿，当然啦，你扮演过杰瑞·刘易斯，而我本来应该在他拍的最后一部电影《麦克斯·罗斯》里演他的儿子。哦，哇。后来凯文·波拉克最终演了那个角色，因为我当时档期冲突，但为了培养默契，我和杰瑞在拉斯维加斯他的办公室里一起待了一天。
at his office in Las Vegas for a day. And that was fascinating because I had grown up with his, I kind of adored him early on. Yeah, yeah, same. Wait, Sean, when did you play Jerry Lewis? 2000. And in what? 99, 2000. What can I see this in?
这太迷人了，因为我是看着他的作品长大的，我早期可以说是非常崇拜他。对，对，我也是。等等，肖恩，你什么时候扮演过杰瑞·刘易斯？2000年。在什么作品里？99年，2000年。我在哪里能看到这个？
A movie, I don't know where it is. It was Jeremy, Jeremy Northam. Northam. Okay, okay. He played Dean Martin. So it was about the duo and they're getting together and they're breaking up, I'm so fascinated. I've read a lot about that.
一部电影，我不知道它在哪里。是杰里米，杰里米·诺瑟姆。诺瑟姆。好吧，好吧。他扮演迪恩·马丁。所以这是关于这个二人组的故事，他们是如何聚在一起又分道扬镳的，我太着迷了。我读过很多关于这方面的书。
What film is this, Sean? Why are you trying to bury it? It's called Dean and Jerry, I don't know. It was a long time ago. Dean and Jerry. And where is it streaming? Is it on Tubi? Because Jason doesn't get Tubi, he's not sure. Well hang on, I don't know. It was a long time ago. Dean and Jerry, and where is it streaming? Is it on Tubi? Because Jason doesn't get Tubi, he's not sure. Well hang on, I don't know.
肖恩，这是什么电影？你为什么要试图掩盖它？它叫《迪恩和杰瑞》，我不知道。那是很久以前的事了。《迪恩和杰瑞》。它在哪里播放？在Tubi上吗？因为杰森不用Tubi，他不太确定。等一下，我不知道。那是很久以前的事了。《迪恩和杰瑞》，它在哪里播放？在Tubi上吗？因为杰森不用Tubi，他不太确定。等一下，我不知道。
Do I get, do I have Tubi? Oh my God, what's that? Oh Martin and Lewis it's called. Martin and Lewis. Was this a TV film? CBS, yeah it was CBS. Oh it was a CBS TV film. Well that's why you're being cagey about it.
我有Tubi吗？哦天哪，那是什么？哦，好像叫《马丁与刘易斯》。《马丁与刘易斯》。这是一部电视电影吗？CBS的，对，是CBS的。哦，是一部CBS的电视电影难怪你对此吞吞吐吐的。
Okay, so listen. I love that, so I don't know if we can talk. No I didn't remember that until he just told me, Scottie just told me. I want to talk about though that comedy duo. I want to talk about Jerry, I want So listen. I love that, so what do I know? I didn't remember that until he just told me, Scottie just told me. I want to talk about that comedy duo, I want to talk about Jerry, I want to talk about Dean, but talking about you guys, how about the trios, how about, which brings me to the three stooges, of course,
好吧，听着。我太喜欢了，所以不知道我们能不能聊。不，直到他刚刚告诉我，斯科蒂刚刚告诉我，我才想起来。不过我想聊聊那个喜剧二人组。我想聊聊杰瑞，我想——所以听着。我太喜欢了，所以我知道什么？直到他刚刚告诉我，斯科蒂刚刚告诉我，我才想起来。我想聊聊那个喜剧二人组，我想聊聊杰瑞，我想聊聊迪恩，不过说到你们，三人组怎么样，这就让我想到了当然是“三个臭皮匠”，
and there's the Marx Brothers. Yeah, yeah. And how about applause. Bravo, I loved it, I loved it. That's commitment, what commitment? Are you kidding me? Bravo, I loved it. I loved it. What commitment? What commitment? Are you kidding me? Bravo. I loved that.
还有马克思兄弟。对，对。还有，掌声鼓励。太棒了，我太喜欢了，我太喜欢了。这真是全身心的投入，太投入了！你在开玩笑吗？太棒了。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。多大的投入！多大的投入！你在开玩笑吗？太棒了。我太喜欢了。
I believed him. I believed every moment of that deal. I was a-threads-ported, oh my God. I was. Now wait, the Three Stooges. I loved when I was a kid. I saw all of their things on television, but listen to this.
我相信了他。我坚信那一刻的那场表演。我被深深地迷住了，天哪。我是的。现在等等，“三个臭皮匠”。我小时候很喜欢。我在电视上看过他们所有的节目，但听着这个。
I saw them live. They came to a place called the Holiday House in 1960. It must have been, you know, two or five or something. And I saw Mo and Larry and Curly Joe at that time. And they came into the audience, I remember, and my sister, two years younger than me, was like five or six or seven. Mo, who had big bags at that point,
我现场看过他们。他们在1960年去了一个叫假日屋（Holiday House）的地方。那一定是在，你知道的，2岁或5岁左右吧。我当时见到了莫、拉里和库利·乔。我记得他们走进了观众席，我妹妹（比我小两岁，大概五六七岁吧）——当时有很大眼袋的莫，
did something to her, kind of aggressive. She burst into tears. And she kind of retreated. He later got his eyes done and didn't have that problem anymore. Wow. Different Moe, different Moe, different Moe. Hey, promises, promises.
对她做了一些举动，有点具有攻击性。她突然放声大哭。她有点退缩了。他后来去做了眼部整形，就再也没有那个问题了。哇。不同的莫，不同的莫，不同的莫。嘿，承诺，承诺。
Oh my God. Jerry Orbach was the original. I love you. And by the way, Jay. I went three times! And you came backstage, and I appreciated that, so thank you. Oh, now we're full circle, now we're full circle.
哦天哪。杰瑞·奥巴赫是原版。我爱你。顺便说一句，杰伊。我去了三次！你还去了后台，我很感激，谢谢你。哦，现在我们又回到了原点，现在我们又回到了原点。
He doesn't remember. All right, let's move on to Jason and Will, or I have a bunch of questions for you. Oscar Levant, listen to this though, my grandmother, Anna Katz, claims she dated Oscar LeVance, who's also at Pittsburgh, on one occasion. I don't know if that meant he flirted with her, if they had some encounter, I don't know what that means.
他不记得了。好吧，我们接着聊杰森和威尔，或者我有一堆问题要问你。奥斯卡·勒万特，听着这个，我的祖母安娜·卡茨声称她曾与奥斯卡·勒万特（也是匹兹堡人）约会过一次。我不知道这是否意味着他对她调情，或者他们有过某种邂逅，我不知道这意味着什么。
But anyway, that's our connection. Sean, you did not discover that during your extensive research? I shouldn't, but I'll use it. Okay. Will Arnett arrest the, well, I saw every episode of Arrested Development. And by the way, you...
不管怎样，这就是我们的联系。肖恩，你在广泛的研究中没有发现这一点吗？我不该知道的，但我会用它的。好吧。威尔·阿奈特，逮捕——好吧，我看过每一集的《发展受阻》。顺便说一句，你……
Bravo! Bravo! Sean did? I know, it's on the Fox Network! Ah, it's amazing! Sean's character goes, what channel was it on? Yeah, exactly. We didn't find it. But I saw it, but I loved all your,
太棒了！太棒了！肖恩看过了？我知道，是在福克斯电视台播出的！啊，太棒了！肖恩的角色说，这是在哪个频道播出的？对，没错。我们没找到。但我看了，我当然喜欢你们所有的，
every character in it of course, Eliza Minnelli, I knew a little bit. And Charlie's Theron, fantastic. But the magician, the magic in that, and I know you've talked about magic before. I did magic in that movie Nashville, and in Wicked I do a little magic. So we could talk about magic.
里面的每一个角色，丽莎·明妮莉，我略知一二。还有查理兹·塞隆，太棒了。但那个魔术师，里面的魔术，我知道你以前谈过魔术。我在电影《纳什维尔》里表演过魔术，在《魔法坏女巫》里我也变了一点魔术。所以我们可以聊聊魔术。
You are magic. You are magic. I bet you strike me, Jeff, as the kind of guy who knows a few card tricks and a few sleight of hand things, do you? Yeah. I know, well, Robert Alton told me to learn some. I had this guy in New York taught me a bag full of tricks.
你就是魔术。你就是魔术。杰夫，我敢说，你在我眼里绝对是那种懂几个纸牌戏法和一些手法魔术的人，对吗？是的。我懂，好吧，罗伯特·奥尔顿叫我学一些。我在纽约时有个家伙教了我一整套戏法。
I brought it to Nashville and we used a bunch of them. The only thing that I've kept up my sleeve are these rope tricks. Oh, boy. Yes, which I've pulled out too many times, and I know that and then I know one card trick. That's all I know, but the rope tricks I can do. The rope tricks.
我把它带到了《纳什维尔》，我们用了很多。我唯一保留的绝活就是这些绳子戏法。哦，天哪。是的，我用得太多了，我知道这一点，然后我还会一个纸牌戏法。这就是我全部会的了，但我会变绳子戏法。绳子戏法。
The rope tricks. That's always tough. You gotta make sure you're in a big group for that. So Jeff. I'm pitching that as a halftime show at the Super Bowl. I think those close-up magic would go over well. Sure. We'll be right back.
绳子戏法。那总是很难。你得确保周围有一大群人才能变那个。所以，杰夫。我正提议把它作为超级碗中场秀呢。我觉得那些近景魔术会很受欢迎。当然。我们马上回来。
And now, back to the show. I want to talk about the famous Jeff Goldblum delivery, which is like, you're known for, it's brilliant, it's made you work. Don't break it down, don't break it down, don't break it down. What do you mean? That's a magic trick.
现在，回到节目中。我想聊聊著名的杰夫·戈布伦式的说话方式，就像是，你因此而闻名，这太棒了，这为你赢得了工作。别把它拆解开来，别拆解开来，别拆解开来！你什么意思？那是个魔术。
No, I thought this was interesting. I read that innovation body snatch of the Body Snatchers, kind of when you kind of discovered this thing, and it was the line, I never thought they would come in metal ships. Is that right? Yes. And now I would say it,
不，我觉得这很有意思。我读到关于《天外魔花》时，差不多就是你发现这种风格的时候，有这样一句台词：我从没想过它们会乘着金属飞船来。是这样吗？是的。现在我会这样说，
I would have never thought they'd come in metal ships, but you would say it. I never thought they'd come in metal ships. I don't know, I'm not making that up. I have no idea. That's really good. By the way, that's really good. That's good. I'm doing a caricature of? I don't know, I'm not making that up. I have no idea. That's really good, by the way, that's really good. I'm doing a caricature of my own, you know, Fumfuture-ing, I don't know.
我绝不会想到它们会乘着金属飞船来，但你会这样说。我从没想过它们会乘着金属飞船来。我不知道，我可不是瞎编的。我完全不知道。这真的很棒。顺便说一句，这真的很棒。这很好。我是在模仿我自己吗？我不知道，我可不是瞎编的。我完全不知道。顺便说一句，这真的很棒，这真的很棒。我是在做我自己的漫画式的，你知道的，未来主义，我不知道。
I don't know what it is. I love that. But it was at that moment that Phil Kaufman said, oh yeah, that's good, I like the way he did that, and I kind of thought to myself, hmm, check note to self, I think, ah, that's something, that's something I can build upon. It's so cool.
我不知道那是什么。我太喜欢了。但就在那一刻，菲尔·卡夫曼说，哦，挺好，我喜欢他刚才那种演绎方式，我当时心里想，嗯，给自己做个笔记，我想，啊，这是个东西，这是我可以继续发扬光大的东西。太酷了。
Something like that. Anyway, so there we go, Horton Here's a Who. Oh boy, I love it. Legos, My Kids and Legos. Now, Ozark, wait a minute, wait a minute. You know, I did this series recently, Chaos, I played Zeus, and you know who played my wife? Janet McTeer.
诸如此类。不管怎样，就这样吧，《霍顿与无名氏》。哦天哪，我太喜欢了。乐高，我的孩子们和乐高。现在，Ozark，等一下，等一下。你知道的，我最近拍了一部剧《混乱》，我扮演宙斯，你知道谁扮演我妻子吗？珍妮特·麦克蒂尔。
Oh boy, she's a beast. She's wonderful. She's beast. She's wonderful. She's incredible. She's incredible and you know who I know a little bit, have not seen her since. When she was like, what, 12, 13, 14, something like that I think, or 15, this girl came backstage,
哦天哪，她太厉害了。她太棒了。她太厉害了。她太棒了。她太不可思议了。她太不可思议了，而且你知道我认识谁一点，之后就再也没见过她。当她大概，什么，12、13、14岁左右吧，或者15岁，这女孩来到后台，
I think this is how it happened, to see me in the pillow man, I did this thing at the Booth Theater with people you know, I enjoyed doing that. So she came back, I think this is how it happened, to see me in the pillow man, I did this thing at the Booth Theater, with people you know, I enjoyed doing that. So she came back, I think then, and said, oh, I like what you do, you know, I wanna be an actress. Maybe, could we talk sometime? And you'll tell, you know, like I have a script,
我想事情是这样的，来看我在《枕头人》里的演出——我在布思剧院演过这个，跟一些你们认识的人，我演得很开心。所以她来到后台，我想事情是这样的，来看我在《枕头人》里的演出，我在布思剧院演过这个，跟一些你们认识的人，我演得很开心。所以她来到后台，我想就是那时，说，哦，我喜欢你做的事，你知道的，我想成为一名演员。也许，我们能聊聊吗？你会告诉——你知道的，就像我有一个剧本，
we could, you know, read something, or, and you'll tell me, I said, sure. She seemed like an interesting and smart girl. That was Julie Garner. Oh wow. Wow. Really? And I have not seen her since.
我们可以，你知道的，读点什么，或者，你会告诉我——我说，当然。她看起来是个有趣又聪明的女孩。那是朱莉娅·加纳。哦，哇。哇。真的吗？从那以后我再也没见过她。
I haven't seen her. To congratulate her on everything that's gone on. She's interesting, isn't she? Oh yeah. What a sweet, sweet person. Just a monster talent. Oh my gosh. Well, you know, and then of course,
我没见过她。去祝贺她取得的一切成就。她很有趣，不是吗？哦，是的。多么甜美、甜美的人啊。简直是个天才怪物。哦天哪。好吧，你知道的，然后当然，
hey, we did the switch, you and I, Dr. Baking. We played Best Friends, yeah. Best Friends. In the switch with Miss Jennifer Aniston, directed by the great. Miss Jennifer Aniston. Yeah, Will Speck, Josh Gordon. And Will Speck and Josh Gordon,
嘿，我们互换过角色，你和我，在《同居牢友》里。我们演了挚友，是的。挚友。在与詹妮弗·安妮斯顿小姐合作的《同居牢友》里，由伟大的——詹妮弗·安妮斯顿小姐导演的。詹妮弗·安妮斯顿小姐。是的，威尔·斯佩克，乔什·戈登。还有威尔·斯佩克和乔什·戈登，
who directed me in some of these apartments.com commercials. I adore them. Is that right? No kidding. By the way, I love those commercials. Will Speck and Josh Gordon, who directed Blades of Glory, that I did years ago. Bravo, I love that. It Speck and Josh Gordon, who directed Blades of Glory that I did a few years ago. He's involved in this degrees of separation.
他们执导了我拍的一些 Apartments.com 广告。我太喜欢他们了。是吗？不是吧。顺便说一句，我太喜欢那些广告了。威尔·斯佩克和乔什·戈登，他们曾执导过我几年前拍的《冰刀双人组》。太棒了，我太喜欢了。是斯佩克和乔什·戈登，他们曾执导过我几年前拍的《冰刀双人组》。他参与了这种“六度分隔理论”。
That's right. Jeff, who were your, you know, you hear these stories about actors like these, like the great Gene Hackman just passed away, and you hear like he was roommates with Robert Duvall and Dustin Hoffman. And then you hear these different people who came up. Who were sort of your gang?
没。杰夫，你的——你知道，你总能听到这样的故事：演员们就像这些，比如伟大的吉恩·哈克曼刚刚去世，你听说他曾和罗伯特·杜瓦尔以及达斯汀·霍夫曼合租。然后你还会听到这些不同的人是怎么出道的。谁算是你的核心朋友圈？
Did you have like a gang of actor friends that we didn't know about, or like people who worked a lot and you guys were all coming up at the same time, or was it a more solitary existence for you? Meaning, did you have no friends? You know, I fit into the more solitary category. Yeah, really? Yeah. Are you an introvert or an extrovert? You know, I fit into the more solitary category. Yeah, really? Yeah.
你有没有我们不知道的演员朋友帮派，或者像那种经常工作、你们都是同时出道的人，还是说对你来说这是一种更加孤独的生活方式？意思是，你没有朋友吗？你知道的，我属于比较孤独的那一类。是吗，真的吗？是的。你是内向还是外向？你知道的，我属于比较孤独的那一类。是吗，真的吗？是的。
Are you an introvert or an extrovert? Do you mind your business and stay in a dark room by yourself, like me? Well, I like time, I have my homework. I'm a good boy and I'm conscientious and I play the piano for an hour every morning and I work out and I like to work on my things. I'd rather not, I don't go to, I don't stay up late
你是内向还是外向？你是不是管好自己的事，自己一个人待在黑屋子里，就像我一样？嗯，我喜欢独处，我有我的家庭作业。我是个好孩子，我很认真，每天早上弹一小时钢琴，我锻炼身体，我喜欢忙自己的事情。我宁愿不，我不熬夜
in order to hang out or all of that stuff. So, you know, there's that. But I'm also- You can be friends with us by the sound of it. Yeah, exactly. You can be friends with us. Yeah, you're hard workers, obviously. But I adore people and I, you know, like I said,
去跟人闲晃或者做那些乱七八糟的事。所以，你知道，就是这样。但我也——听起来你完全可以跟我们做朋友。对，没错。你可以跟我们做朋友。是的，你们显然都是努力工作的人。但我崇拜人们，而且我，正如我所说，
I can imagine being pals with you and I have a good friend, Gary and Ed Begley Jr. is a good friend of mine. I love him. I love him. From the rest of the band, we love Ed Begley so much. We love him. Now, are you a concert pianist like our friend Sean Hayes?
我能想象和你们成为死党，我有个好朋友叫加里，小埃德·贝格利也是我的好朋友。我太爱他了。我太爱他了。从乐队其他人那儿来看，我们太爱埃德·贝格利了。我们太爱他了。那么，你是一位像我们朋友肖恩·海耶斯那样的音乐会钢琴家吗？
He's a incredibly accomplished jazz pianist. I don't know, I'm a humble student, but I do like the jazz. I started off getting the chops playing Charney and John Thompson's stuff. And this and that, and then discovered the fake books and now called the real books and jazz, and I fell in love with that, and that's what happened.
他是一位极其出色的爵士钢琴家。我不知道，我只是个谦逊的学生，但我确实喜欢爵士乐。我一开始是靠练习车尔尼和约翰·汤普森的东西来打基础的。这个那个的，后来发现了假书（Fake Books），现在叫真实之书（Real Books）和爵士乐，我爱上了那个，事情就是这样。
And then 30 years ago, now I put it in some movies, the fly character plays the piano, and in Earth, Pearls, and Reeds, and I play the piano. Yes, that's right. And in plays, I put it in a couple of plays, and then 30 years ago, Peter Weller said, hey, we did this movie by Kerbanzai,
然后在30年前，现在我把它放进了一些电影里，那个变蝇人的角色会弹钢琴，在《地球与天空》里，我也弹钢琴。是的，没错。在戏剧里，我把它放进了几部戏剧里，然后30年前，彼得·韦勒说，嘿，我们拍了部柯南伯格的电影，
he said, let's get together and play a little bit, and then a couple of people, Miles Davis, who he knows, and said, oh, you and Jeff should go out and play a gig, and you'll get better and enjoy it, and that's what we started to do. So 30 years ago, I've had this group, Peter Weller kind we started to do. So 30 years ago I've had this group, Peter Weller kind of went off and did wonderful things but I've kept this group.
他说，我们聚在一起随便弹一点吧，然后有几个人，迈尔斯·戴维斯（他认识的），说，哦，你和杰夫应该出去演出一场，这样你们会有所进步并乐在其中，这就是我们开始做的事。所以30年前，我就有了这个乐队，彼得·韦勒——我们开始做的事。所以30年前我就有了这个乐队，彼得·韦勒去做了其他很棒的事，但我保留了这个乐队。
Peter Weller who also worked with David Cronenberg on Naked Lunch and who's also a cousin of Fred Weller, my good friend, theater actor. Love Fred Weller, I saw him on a play, I saw him on stage but how about speaking of the movie game. So Naked Lunch takes us to Judy Davis. I've never met her, but I adore her. She's great, yeah.
彼得·韦勒还曾与大卫·柯南伯格合作过《裸体午餐》，他也是我的好朋友、戏剧演员弗雷德·韦勒的表弟。我很喜欢弗雷德·韦勒，我看过他的戏剧演出，我在舞台上看过他。不过说到电影界，《裸体午餐》让我们想到了朱迪·戴维斯。我从未见过她，但我崇拜她。她太棒了，是的。
I'm a big fan of hers. Which takes us to husbands and wives, which takes us to Sidney Pollock or many other people. You had a role in Annie Hall as well, so that takes us where we're going. Sure did. So wait, Jeff, has jazz music, like playing jazz music, have you ever had to make a decision
我是她的超级粉丝。这又让我们想到了《丈夫和妻子》，让我们想到了西德尼·波拉克或许多其他人。你在《安妮·霍尔》里也有个角色，所以这顺理成章地承接了我们要去的地方。确实如此。等等，杰夫，爵士乐——比如弹奏爵士乐，你有没有过必须在表演工作和音乐之间做出抉择的时候？
about doing acting work over your music? Or do you always kind of make sure everything's separate? Separate, they went on parallel tracks. Like I said, at 10, I had my heart set on being an actor in my life as a career. Like have you ever turned down a big movie because you're like, I can't, I have a gig. Nope, nope, I have not.
还是说你总是确保这两者是分开的？分开的，它们在平行的轨道上进行。就像我说的，在10岁时，我心里就认定了一生要当演员，要把它作为职业。比如说你有没有因为“我有演出”而拒绝过一部大电影？没有，没有，我没有。
As a matter of fact, I have gigs coming up. We have our fourth album on deck and we're coming out April 25th. And so in support of that, we're going to these places to play. We're gonna play the Palladium in London. We're gonna be in Toronto at Massey Hall, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
事实上，我接下来还有很多演出。我们的第四张专辑即将推出，将在4月25日发行。为了配合专辑宣传，我们要去这些地方演出。我们要去伦敦帕拉丁剧院演出。我们要去多伦多的梅西音乐厅，等等，等等，等等。
Give us some dates on those. Do you have dates on those, Jeff? Let's get a plug in here. April 25 Hall, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera. Give us some dates, give us some dates on those. You have dates on those, Jeff? Let's get a plug in here. April 25th, this may, by the time people hear this, may be too late, but we will have been at the Palladium and my two boys who play the piano, and I work with them, they have a great teacher, but I work with them, are gonna come on stage with,
给我们说几个具体的日期。你有那些日期吗，杰夫？让我们在这儿打个广告。4月25日音乐厅，等等，等等，等等。给我们几个日期，给我们报一下那些日期。你有那些日期吗，杰夫？让我们在这儿打个广告。4月25日，当人们听到这个时可能已经晚了，但我们那时已经在帕拉丁剧院演出过了，我的两个弹钢琴的男孩——我和他们一起合作，他们有一个很好的老师，但我跟他们一起合作——他们要跟我一起上台，
it's a surprise, nobody knows yet, they're gonna come on stage with me and play something. I hope that's not abusive. I hope they have a good experience. And that's what it's for. Anyway, we'll be there, then Luxembourg, we go and then on the 26th, April, then May 25th, Atlanta, Symphony Hall,
这是一个惊喜，现在还没人知道，他们将和我一起上台弹奏一曲。我希望这不算虐童。我希望他们能有一段美好的经历。这就是它的意义所在。不管怎样，我们会在那儿，然后去卢森堡，然后4月26日，接着是5月25日，亚特兰大交响音乐厅，
May 27th to the 31st, we'll be at the Cafe Carlisle in New York City. You've been to Carlisle? Of course. I've played there before. I saw you play at the Troubadour, I think a long, long time ago. You're mixing me up with Bob Dylan or something.
5月27日到31日，我们将在纽约市的卡莱尔咖啡厅（Cafe Carlyle）。你去过卡莱尔咖啡厅吗？当然。我以前在那里演出过。我想很久很久以前我在特鲁巴多（Troubadour）看过你演出。你把我跟鲍勃·迪伦或者什么人搞混了吧。
No, no, I've never played at the Troubadour. Then it was somewhere else in LA. It was like a, I just, anyway, it was incredible. I've been all over the LA, yes, and I did a play at the Whiskey-a-Gogo down the block from the Troubadour, believe it or not. El Granado de Coco, yes, it was a cabaret theater. Any good theater stories from the Whiskey-a-Go-Go down the block from the play. Believe it or not, Elgrinat-a-Go-Go, yes, it was a cabaret theater. Any good theater stories from The Whiskey-a-Go-Go?
不，不，我从未在特鲁巴多演出过。那是在洛杉矶的某个别的地方。就像一个，我只是——不管怎样，那太不可思议了。我去过洛杉矶的各个地方，是的，我在威士忌果戈里（Whisky a Go Go）演过一出戏，就在特鲁巴多街区往下走，信不信由你。椰林俱乐部（El Granado de Coco），是的，那是一个歌舞剧院。关于威士忌果戈里街区往下走的剧院有什么好故事吗？信不信由你，椰林果戈里，是的，那是一个歌舞剧院。关于威士忌果戈里有什么好戏剧故事吗？
Anything happen there that was, Sean, sorry to cut into your moment of long. Jeff, I always ask people if you have any crazy, like, mishap theaters. I know you do. All right. I know you do. Well, I did the Moony Shapiro songbook,
那里发生过什么让人——肖恩，抱歉打断你那段漫长的时刻。杰夫，我总是问别人你有没有什么疯狂的戏剧事故。我知道你有的。好吧。我知道你有的。嗯，我演过《穆尼·夏皮罗歌集》，
which there were five of us, Judy. Garland. Gary Beach was in it. Gary Beach. Yeah of us, Judy, Gary Beach was in it. Gary Beach. Yeah, Gary Beach, of course. He was there, just five of us, singing and dancing. We were at the Morosco Theater, and we were rehearsed for four weeks. We previewed for two weeks, opening night.
我们有五个人，朱迪。加兰。加里·比奇在里面。加里·比奇。是的，有我们几个，朱迪，加里·比奇在里面。加里·比奇。是的，加里·比奇，当然。他在那儿，只有我们五个人，唱歌跳舞。我们在莫罗斯科剧院，我们排练了四周。我们预演了两周，首演之夜。
It seemed to go well. The reviews came out. They weren't so great for the play. I got nice reviews. And then Stuart Ostro called me up and said, so, we're not gonna be doing it anymore. What, what do you mean? Well, Tuesday, well, Tuesday, this coming Tuesday,
看起来进展顺利。评论出炉了。对这出剧的评价不是那么好。我得到了不错的评价。然后斯图尔特·奥斯特罗打电话给我说，嗯，我们不演了。什么，什么意思？嗯，周二，嗯，周二，这个周二，
we're off tomorrow or Monday, no, no, no, that's all, we didn't sell enough advance tickets, and the reviews didn't, so it closed opening night. So that's a kind of a, I don't know how funny that story is, but. So wait's the kind of a, I don't know how funny that story is. So wait, so Jurassic Park, I just want to talk for two seconds because I was so jealous when you,
我们明天或周一休息，不，不，不，就这样，我们预售票没卖够，而且评论也不好，所以在首演之夜就闭幕了。所以这是一个——我不知道这个故事有多搞笑，但。所以等等，是《侏罗纪公园》，我只想聊两秒钟，因为当我看到你时我太嫉妒了，
I was signing a talk show and you had your own lyrics to the melody and I had my own lyrics that I was singing for years and years and it was. Oh shit, put a wallet in his mouth. Sorry. And do you remember yours yours mine went like this. Kill the dinosaurs, kill the dinosaurs, kill them all before they eat you.
我当时在给一个脱口秀签名，你为那个旋律填了自己的歌词，而我有自己填的歌词，我唱了好多年好多年，它就是——哦操，往他嘴里塞个钱包。抱歉。你还记得你的吗，你的——我的词是这样的：杀死恐龙，杀死恐龙，在它们吃掉你之前把它们全杀光。
And that was all I had. And then you came on and I was because it's... And you had years to work on that yourself? It begs for lyrics, doesn't it? Fuck, yeah. I don't know if it begs for it, but here's mine. Here's all I know. In Jurassic Park, scary in the dark, I'm so scared that I'll be eaten.
这就是我的全部歌词。然后你上场了，因为它是——你花了好多年自己琢磨这个？这简直是在求着别人填词，对吧？他妈的，是的。我不知道它是不是在求着填词，但这是我的。这就是我所知道的。在《侏罗纪公园》，黑暗中真可怕，我好害怕自己被吃掉。
That's good. Bravo. This is a lyric. Now, Jeff, with all of the films that you've done, all the projects that you've done, you've done it all. The way that you choose what job to do, has it changed over the years since you've checked so many boxes?
这挺好。太棒了。这是一段歌词。现在，杰夫，凭借你拍过的所有电影，所有的项目，你什么都经历过了。你选择工作的方式，自从你完成了这么多的成就之后，这些年有没有发生改变？
Like, what gets you to work? What gets you to say yes nowadays? A good question. Well, it's always fluid, as you know, and that's always clarifying itself as the days and the weeks go on. But now, as I have this family, which I adore, and these two little boys,
比如，是什么促使你去工作？如今是什么让你说“好”的？好问题。嗯，正如你所知，这总是变动不居的，随着日子和周数的推移，它总是变得越来越清晰。但现在，因为我有了这个我挚爱的家庭，还有这两个小男孩，
it's not just for any reason that I'm gonna go off to the ends of the earth for a year, or do all sorts of things. So it has to be special, and my own criteria, you know, when I was, when Sandy, I took to heart what Sandy Meisner said, and it takes 20 years of constant work and then a lifetime of continual work if you get opportunities to keep growing,
我不会因为随随便便的理由就离家一年去天涯海角，或者去做各种各样的杂事。所以它必须是特别的，根据我自己的标准——你知道的，当我当年，桑迪·迈斯纳说的话我铭记在心：需要20年的持续工作，然后如果你有幸获得机会继续成长，则需要一生的持续不断的工作，
and that's a good worthwhile way to spend your life. I took that to heart. But I went through a couple of decades where I worked a lot and wanted to work and wanted to work more and exercise myself and test myself and find out what I had in me and et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
这是度过一生的一个好的、有价值的方式。我把这话听进去了。但我经历过几个十年，那时我工作很多，想要工作，想要做更多的工作来锻炼自己、考验自己、发掘自己身体里有什么，等等，等等，等等。
Now, yes, I have as big an appetite as ever for creative, the creative experience so-called. But I don't have to, I don't have to work every day. I don't feel ashamed if I'm not working every day. That's okay. And so I wanna do special things, special, special things, whatever that means. But talk about that, what I thought you were about to say
现在，是的，我对创意、所谓的创意体验依然有着和以往一样巨大的胃口。但我不用，我不用每天都工作。如果我没有每天都工作，我也不会感到羞耻。没关系。所以我想做特别的事，特别、特别的事，无论那意味着什么。不过聊聊那个吧，我刚才以为你要说的是
about you went through a period where it was all about testing yourself. So that was kind of what drove your decisions. And now are you feeling like, I don't wanna put words in your mouth, but it's not like you don't have things to prove to yourself anymore, but is it less of an urgency?
关于你经历过一段全是为了考验自己的时期。所以那曾是驱动你做决定的动力。而现在你觉得——我不想把话说进你嘴里——但并不是说你对自我已经无所证明了，只是那种紧迫感不那么强了？
Like, yeah? Yes, it's less urgent, although in another way, more urgent, because as we know, time is running out, and I still feel like I'm doing my best work. I feel at the top of my form, I'm injury-free, and I feel like I'm doing my best work. I feel at the top of my form, I'm injury free, and I feel like I'm enjoying it more than ever, I'm freer than ever, and can do my best work.
就像是，对吗？是的，没那么紧迫了，不过从另一个角度来看，却更加紧迫了，因为我们知道，时间正在流逝，而我依然觉得自己正在创作我最好的作品。我觉得自己处于巅峰状态，没有伤病，而且我觉得自己正在创作我最好的作品。我觉得自己处于巅峰状态，没有伤病，并且我觉得自己比以往任何时候都更享受其中，比以往任何时候都更自由，能够创作出我最好的作品。
So I feel like grand things could be ahead. And you've satisfied whatever sort of personal doubt might be the wrong word, that whatever you were working through there and sort of having fun exploring, now you've sort of found this place of, not satisfaction, but just sort of like, I feel...
所以我感觉更伟大的事情还在前方。而且你已经满足了某种个人内心的怀疑——“怀疑”可能用词不当——无论你在那段时期经历过什么、通过探索获得什么乐趣，现在你都已经找到了这样一种状态：不是满足感，而是一种……
Content. Thank you. And now work takes on a different role, perhaps. I'm asking all this because I feel like I'm playing with it myself. Well, you're intuitive. You're a good therapist, you're a good friend. Well, we talk about it all the time, don't we?
知足。谢谢。现在工作扮演了不同的角色，也许吧。我问这一切是因为我觉得我自己也在经历这个。嗯，你很有直觉。你是个好心理医生，你是个好朋友。嗯，我们一直在讨论这个，不是吗？
Like the balance and what are the things that truly make us happy, right? And the way that we measure our happiness or our joy, it evolves over time, especially when you add sort of kids and family and experience and age and all those things. Work represents a different thing in different decades. Yeah, yeah, yeah. All of that. we could talk about all of that at length, but yeah that I I'm in the same ballpark
比如平衡感，以及真正让我们快乐的事情是什么，对吧？我们衡量幸福感或快乐的方式在不断演变，特别是当你加上孩子、家庭、经历、年龄和所有这些元素时。在不同的十年里，工作代表着不同的意义。对，对，对。所有这些。我们可以详细讨论所有这些，但对，我也有同感。
That's that's right and movies we could talk about it over on smartless after hours our new podcast Well, I like this long form this long form is great to me I mean I like the six seven minutes you spend on these talk shows. And you know, that's another kind of thing which would be fun to talk about. But I like these, I like listening to them. It's more of a conversation. Yeah, I love it too.
没错，我们可以去我们的新播客《聪明无知：下班后》上讨论电影。嗯，我喜欢这种长访谈，这种长访谈对我很棒，我是说我喜欢你在这些脱口秀上花的区区六七分钟。你知道的，那是另一种形式，聊起来会很有趣。但我喜欢这些，我喜欢听这些。这更像是一场对话。是的，我也很喜欢。
Yeah, I do too. And then we're gonna end on, by the way, thanks for being in Italy and talking to us for an hour. I mean, this is incredible. I mean, I can't believe it. What time is it there? It is, you know, say, oh, a quarter of eight. Oh, that's not a good time. The kids are already, I can't believe, what time is it there? This, it is, you know, it's like, oh, a quarter of eight. Oh, that's not it.
是的，我也是。最后我们要结束了，顺便说一句，谢谢你在意大利还抽一个小时跟我们聊天。我是说，这太不可思议了。我是说，我简直不敢相信。那边几点啦？现在是，你知道的，差不多七点一刻。哦，那可不是个好时间。孩子们已经——我简直不敢相信，那边几点啦？这，差不多，你知道的，七点一刻。哦，那不是——
The kids are already, I know, I said hello, but they're now in bed. So it's two. No, no, no. No. Oh, sorry, two, but I'm sorry, I was thinking, two is a quarter of eight. All right.
孩子们已经——我知道，我打过招呼了，但他们现在已经上床睡觉了。所以是两点。不，不，不。不。哦，抱歉，两点，但抱歉，我在想，两点就是七点一刻。好吧。
Oh, yeah, quarter of eight. Well, it was Sharpie today. Yeah, look at that. Wow. Sorry. Anyway, hey, you know who sings on our new album is Scarlett Johansson and Ariana Grande and Cynthia Erivo. They have songs.
哦，对，七点一刻。嗯，今天脑子挺灵光。对，你看那。哇。抱歉。不管怎样，嘿，你知道谁在我们的新专辑里献唱吗？是斯嘉丽·约翰逊、阿丽亚娜·格兰德和辛西娅·埃里沃。她们有各自的歌曲。
Half are instrumentals and half are singers, and they sing. How about that? That's incredible. Now, Wicked was probably as successful as everyone thought it might be, thank God and deservedly so. There is a second one coming that you've already shot
一半是纯音乐，一半是歌手，她们会唱歌。觉得怎么样？太不可思议了。现在，《魔法坏女巫》可能和每个人想象的一样成功，感谢上帝，实至名归。第二部要上映了，你们已经拍完了，
or that you're going to shoot? No, no, we've already shot it. We shot them all at once, but they're editing it and scoring it and special effectsing it. And a fun process, I'll bet, despite all the special effects and the wardrobes and all those things. Wardrobe, it was fantastic, you know,
还是准备去拍？不，不，我们已经拍完了。我们是一次性拍完的，但他们现在正在剪辑、配乐和做特效。这一定是个有趣的过程，尽管有特效、服装和所有这些东西。服装太棒了，你知道的，
he won an Oscar for that. Yeah, that was great. But John M. Chu is a delightful director and a very, very masterful director and that cast and Jonathan Bailey, whom I saw here in Richard the Second the night before, the Seagull show, by the way, he was terrific, and Ariana and Cynthia, it was aull show, by the way. He was terrific, and Ariana and Cynthia.
他为此赢得了奥斯卡奖。是的，那太棒了。但朱浩伟（John M. Chu）是一位令人愉快的导演，也是一位非常非常精湛的导演，还有那个演员阵容，乔纳森·贝利（我在前一天的《理查二世》里看过他演出，还有海鸥的演出，顺便说一句，他太棒了），还有阿丽亚娜和辛西娅，太棒了。海鸥演出，顺便说一句。他太棒了，还有阿丽亚娜和辛西娅。
In fact, it was a magical and great, great experience. I loved that show when I first saw it with Idina Menzel and Kristin Chenoweth, and cried my eyes out at that, and so I loved playing that. Joel Gray played the part originally on stage, you know. Oh yeah? Yeah, it's great, yeah. Well, just great congratulations on that huge success. big congrats. Yes, that's amazing.
事实上，这是一次神奇而伟大的经历。我第一次看伊迪娜·门泽尔和克里斯汀·肯诺恩斯出演那部剧时就爱上了它，当时我哭得稀里哗啦，所以我非常喜欢演那个角色。你知道的，乔尔·格雷最初在舞台上扮演过这个角色。哦，是吗？是的，太棒了，是的。嗯，恭喜你取得如此巨大的成功。太棒了。是的，这太神奇了。
You're a Titan. It's always so fun to see you in anything. So when you pop on the screen, you're like, ah, I'm gonna be taken care of. Truly, truly, you elevate, you raise all boats, my friend. You raise all boats. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Thank you.
你是个巨星。看你演的任何作品总是那么有趣。所以当你出现在屏幕上时，你会觉得，啊，我会得到照顾的。真的，真的，你提升了所有人，你让所有船只都浮起来了，我的朋友。你让所有的船都水涨船高。是的，是的，是的。谢谢你。
Well, you are so fun, this is a great honor. I hope we see each other often and immediately. Get back to this country. But I know now comes the part of the show. I'll say my farewells. And now, nobody's sung this song because you always say nice things afterwards and you have a little recap and a debriefing.
嗯，你太有趣了，这真是个巨大的荣幸。我希望我们能经常且立刻见面。回到这个国家来。但我知道现在到了节目的这个环节。我要告别了。现在，没有人唱过这首歌，因为你事后总是说好听的话，而且你有一个小总结和回顾。
But you know that song? Please don't talk about me when I'm gone. Yeah, you know that song? Please don't talk about me when I'm gone. Yes, of course. That's a good thing. And then of course, do you know that song from Oliver? You know any songs from Oliver, Shawn?
但你知道那首歌吗？请在我走后不要谈论我。是的，你知道那首歌吗？请在我走后不要谈论我。是的，当然。这是一件好事。然后当然，你知道《雾都孤儿》里的那首歌吗？肖恩，你知道《雾都孤儿》里的任何歌吗？
Well, who will this glory be? No, I know as long as he needs me. Yeah, but who will I this glory be? Who will I this glory be? I don't know, I don't know. What is it?
嗯，谁会买下这份荣耀？不，我知道“只要他需要我”。是的，但是谁会我买下这份荣耀呢？谁会我买下这份荣耀呢？我不知道，我不知道。是什么？
Who will buy. Buy. Oh, Jeff Goldwyn. Wait,. What is it? Who will buy? Oh! Oh! Shafko! Wait, what are the words? Who will buy what? Who will buy this floor is something, something, something. Who will buy this drop, da, da, da, da.
谁会买。买。哦，杰夫·戈德温。等等，是什么？谁会买？哦！哦！沙夫科！等等，歌词是什么？谁会买什么？谁会买这地板是某某某。谁会买这个水滴，哒，哒，哒，哒。
Okay. Thank you, I guess has never given us a buy. Given us a buy, okay, well now you've given us so good. I love it. You've given us an out. And of course, I sung on one of those albums, I sang, little man you're crying, I know why you're blue, which is a version of a, what you sing to your kids
好的。谢谢你，我想（他）从来没有给我们买过（buy）。给我们买过，好吧，现在你给我们表现得真好。我喜欢。你给我们找了个退路。当然，我在其中一张专辑里唱过，我唱了“小家伙你在哭，我知道你为什么忧郁”，这是你唱给你孩子听的版本的其中之一
when they go to bed, a, lullaby. Oh! There's another one. Save it, save it, save it, save it, save it, save it. He's waving goodbye. All right, Jeff, thank you so much. Thank you, we love you. I love you so, so much.
当他们上床睡觉时，这是一首催眠曲。哦！还有另一个。省省吧，省省吧，省省吧，省省吧，省省吧。他在挥手告别。好了，杰夫，非常感谢。谢谢你，我们爱你。我非常非常爱你。
Goodbye, I'll see you soon. Bravo, bravo, bravo. Bravo, bravo, bravo. That was amazing. Yeah, he's great. Jeff Goldblum. We didn't even get to Wes Anderson. He's worked with all the greatest directors, Wes Anderson, Steven Spielberg.
再见，回头见。太棒了，太棒了，太棒了。太棒了，太棒了，太棒了。太精彩了。是的，他太棒了。杰夫·戈布伦。我们甚至还没聊到韦斯·安德森。他合作过所有最伟大的导演，韦斯·安德森、史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格。
Something like 80 films or something. It's like it's insane. Like almost no bad ones. No, almost no bad ones and always happy. Always happy. Always happy. And again, another one of those never a bad performance. Yeah, almost no bad ones and always happy. Always happy. Always happy. And again, another one of those never a bad performance. Yeah, you never catch him acting. He's just always doing, he's got his own rhythm
大概拍了80部电影左右。简直太疯狂了。几乎没有烂片。不，几乎没有烂片，而且总是很高兴。总是很高兴。总是很高兴。而且又是一个从来没有演技差过的人。对，几乎没有烂片，而且总是很高兴。总是很高兴。总是很高兴。而且又是一个从来没有演技差过的人。对，你从抓不到他在演戏的痕迹。他总是在做事，他有自己的节奏
and you know what I think, you were right not to sort of dissect his thing and not that I would know how, but if I were to guess. Well, no, I only did it because I read that he likes to talk about it. Well, but it's like, you can see the next thought coming into his head and so he races through the old thought to get to the new, like, he's always like, that's it.
你知道我觉得什么吗，你当时没去剖析他的那一套是对的，倒不是说我知道怎么剖析，但如果让我猜的话。嗯，不，我这么做只是因为我读到过他喜欢谈论这个。嗯，但是，你可以看到他的下一个想法正涌入脑海，所以他匆忙抛开旧想法去迎接新想法，就像，他总是这样，就是这样。
I don't know, I try to do, I try to think about what I'm gonna say before I say it, which is how the brain works, you know? But in acting, you have the line in front of you. You know what's coming and that's the missing point. You have to sort of like get the thought first. But sometimes don't you feel like, I didn't want him to share it.
我不知道，我尽量在说之前想好我要说什么，这就是大脑工作的方式，对吧？但在表演中，台词就在你面前。你知道接下来会发生什么，而这正是关键所在。你必须先领会那个想法。但有时你是不是觉得，我其实不想让他分享这个。
Like you don't want to know too much how the sausage is made. And Sean, correct me if I'm wrong. You just want to enjoy the sausage. Sausage, that is correct. Right. Yeah, just the sausage, correct. Yeah, that is right.
就像你不想知道香肠是怎么做出来的一样。肖恩，如果我错了请纠正我。你只想享受香肠。香肠，完全正确。对。没错，只要香肠，对。对，就是这样。
That is correct. You can keep the casing on it or cut the casing. It doesn't matter. You can be cut or untied. Massage the casing and make sure it's all evenly. Oh boy. Boy, that took a real turn, man. I tell ya.
没。你可以保留外壳，也可以切掉外壳。这无所谓。你可以切开，也可以解开。按摩外壳，确保它整体均匀。天哪。天哪，这可真是来了个大转折，老兄。我跟你说。
That took a real turn. What about the, what's that song from Oliver you said? What was it? Who Will? No. Bye. Oh no. No, I think the better image is just sort of like
这可真是来了个大转折。那首，奥利弗里的那首歌叫什么来着？是什么？谁会？不。拜拜。哦不。不，我觉得更好的画面大概是
a nice peaceful house there in the Italian countryside. Yeah, and the families go into bed. Yeah, the kids go, you go to sleep, you go to sleep. And then you might sing them something, right, Sean? How would that song go? Like what? La la bye and good night. Oh my god.
意大利乡下一栋宁静美好的房子。对，然后家人们上床睡觉。对，孩子们去睡吧，你去睡吧，你去睡吧。然后你可能会给他们唱点什么，对吧，肖恩？那首歌会怎么唱？比如什么？啦啦，宝贝晚安，晚安。哦天哪。
You got somewhere you gotta go? Yeah, that's lazy. I mean... La la bye. Here we go. La la bye. Say la la bye. Bye.
你有什么地方非去不可吗？好吧，太懒了。我是说……啦啦再见。我们走吧。啦啦再见。说啦啦再见。再见。
Or you know what? Just bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry and Rob Armjarf. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者你知道吗？直接再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。SmartLess 由 Bennett Barbico、Michael Grant Terry 和 Rob Armjarf 100% 有机手工制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。